and welcome back here to round four from the tata
steel chess tournament apologies about that we had
some internet issues on site but we are all back
now and daniel shall we just straight uh jump
straight back into the action definitely let's
let's take a look at where the games are and um
we can maybe start with the game that i think
we left off on which is the jordan run forest
against magnus carlson battle one of the sort
of definitely one of the key games of the day
well every game featuring the world champion is
going to be a game of the day but let's take a
look at what happened when we left off so we saw
that magnus had basically traded a lot of the
pieces he taken on a4 and he had set this devilish
trap for jordan if jordan takes back an a4 i think
this move queen b3 would have been very nasty
targeting that d3 pawn and once that d3 pawn falls
then the d4 pawn is a very dangerous pass but
jordan very astutely does not take he goes and
said queen d1 trying to take the pawn with
his queen with his queen and after queen v5
he goes 94 he finally puts his knife on
e4 and instead of rushing to take the pawn
he makes sure that his pawns are protected that
pawn on a4 is basically a sitting duck so i think
he's trying to take it at his leisure but magnus
rook to be follows attacking that pawn on b2
now i think that we're very very close to this
game just ending in a draw if jordan takes on a4
after queen takes b2 queen
takes b2 rook takes b2 of course
magnus is threatening a back rank mate but my
guess is that something like this is going to
happen fiona and uh notice that white is now
forking white is now forking the a6 pawn and
the d4 pawn and magnus cannot defend both at the
same time this does seem like something close to
a draw but maybe f5 is a little bit nasty jordan
does have a couple of things to solve here maybe
g4 is a little bit more precise here in order to
prevent it but i do think however that this game
will end in a draw i like your suggestion of g4
and it actually this game is very reminiscent
of the one that magnus had yesterday you know
where he has the tiniest of advantages uh but
it's all down to his opponent just finding
at the most precise way to to get to the draw
indeed and we saw jordan doing that against baby
in round one he found a brilliant idea really
nothing short of brilliant in a difficult rook
end game and i think that we we should definitely
expect him to to find g4 as he plays rook takes
84 quite confidently he's got a lot of time
on his clock as well so not a horrible result
for magnus i mean drawing with black in general
you know he's often done that kind of thing you
know draw some games with black wind with white
but um although this is a long tournament at some
point you'll need to start generating more chances
yeah he will especially i think in this
kind of field it will take a big score to
to win the tournament and despite magnus saying
in the opening ceremony he would rather take
ten points and second place rather than nine
points and first i still don't quite believe
that to be true i think magnus more than anything
wants to wants to win this tournament oh yeah you
definitely you want to win the turn i think he
wants to get 10 points and win the tournament i
think that that is the ideal scenario but we
will keep an eye as uh this game enters what
may seem to be its final stage and we will update
you as the queens are very likely to get traded
off the board shortly uh let's take a look at some
of the other games my eye is caught by the game of
ali reza perusa shall we have a look at that one
yeah things are heating up so interestingly you
suggested h5 at some point just before we
left it off and that is what happened then
that pun is no longer no longer alive it
is not and basically we had discussed that
if aryan takes on h5 that seems inadvisable
on account of queen h4 attacking the bishop
the bishop cannot move because queen takes
h2 he's checkmate notice the rook on h8
instead aryan played bishop e3 deploying
his bishop and ali reza goes queen b6
he doesn't wait around on d8 he uses his queen
to pressure that pawn on b2 which has been newly
weakened by the development of the bishop
so aryan defends it and alireza plays f6
and uh the rest just rips open the position
opens up the center and tries to get this
e5 pawn which is kind of one of the prides of
white's position out of them now what i one key
idea is that if white plays out four here notice
that that bishop on e3 is unprotected which means
that after f65 f takes c5 i think black can play
knight d takes e5 and if you take the knight then
of course black takes the bishop on e3 that's
a key detail which means that aryan has to part
ways with that e5 pawn and he's decided to do
that by taking on h5 now pinning the knight
black no longer has these ideas with queen h4
because the queen is on v6 but ali reza has
taken on e5 and here we stand very sharp position
fiona lots going on and uh it just looks like
anybody's game here yeah well my first question to
you is what if i just recaptured that pawn on e5
hit your queen and try and hold on to try and hold
on to that point for dear life is there any way
no that's definitely i think very sensible and one
idea that that came to me as i was meditating on
this position is well if queen c7 then definitely
i think f4 makes a lot of sense and even here
i mean i don't think that ali reza needs to do
anything immediately i think he can just develop
and perhaps castle and get his bishop out to c5
the thing is black is down upon but that material
advantage in such a sharp position isn't really
felt there's another thing to notice here which
is that the long-term weakness of the h file
could give black this long-term attack black
could develop his bishop also to e7 and then
and then consider doubling rooks on a chain so
uh i don't think elijah should fall into the trap
of assuming that he has to attack fast here but
another idea for d65 might be to go queen to d8
and uh this is probably very dubious but i thought
it might be an interesting idea to uh go back to
that old idea of getting the queen to h4 which
i would agree is not kind of as dangerous as
it used to be because here white can take on
g6 and then go knight f3 and defend h2 but perhaps
getting that bishop is a win a small win for black
so several things to decide here i think darion
is quite likely to take on e5 although he can also
prioritize his development with something like
92. a final question before we move on uh if he
takes on e5 is bishop c5 another option for black
definitely no that's that's the first thing that
i was going to uh suggest and that's definitely
a good catch developing and defending the queen
and after bishop takes c5 i would imagine well
i mean actually knight takes c5 is possible as
well but queen c5 looks quite sensible just to
keep the d7 knight on on that square to attack e5
and uh you know maybe well the problem is
white can't move the queen you know i would
love to play the move queen to d4 but we can't
forget the bishop is hanging and i really don't
want to take on g6 either so absolutely fiona i
think that's very much possible in response to dd
yeah a lot of things to consider here
ferrari entirely we will leave him to
it but we'll keep a close eye close eye on the
game i'm sure we check in with fabiano carrana
sure yeah that's a game we we haven't checked in
on in a while and 21 moves have been played so we
we had checked in when hari krishna had gone
bishop to e3 and this kind of sharp uh archangel
ryan lopez fabi uh we remind you could not have
taken on e4 because of this move d5 that would
bring a lot of blacks minor pieces under
fire and win a b so fab he takes on d4 he
trades pawns and he goes 97. by the way very
interesting sorry dania because i i see that
we have the jordan against magnus game so we
are looking at a harry krishna against fabiano
uh but we have jordan on camera has he played i
think you suggested they seem to be all of this
has happened yeah all of this has happened queen
b2 take stakes now the key move g4 is stopping
uh f5 and now of course rook b6 magnus preserving
the uh a pawn rook takes d4 and king of phase and
this is definitely equal the tiniest of
edges for black literally the tiniest
because black has the slightly better passport
and bishops are generally better at supervising
fast pawns than our knights but that is a one darn
good night and it's basically unassailable for the
time being because f5 is impossible rook g7 comes
to mind generally in these end games rooks belong
behind past pawns so that's one idea uh but you
know that's definitely not the only one yeah
so for some reason the computer isn't a huge fan
of it but i'm not really sure why i mean this is
such a tempting move getting the rook behind the
passport making sure that that passer doesn't go
doesn't run all the way to a3 the only thing that
i was wondering about is uh could i have used well
i guess it's passive but could i have used my my
uh my rook to block your pawn from a4 is there any
way for you now and now that the rook has gone
behind upon is there any way black can get the
pawn all the way to a3 yeah i mean that's that's
certainly an option to consider i mean i think
magnus's idea in that case yeah necessarily
immediately just to maybe make you generally deny
on on that square i'm just trying to understand
yeah what's wrong uh what's wrong no i think
that's definitely impossible you could just not
move the work at all because as you say the rook
is restraining upon and not allowing it to move
to a4 so maybe you could have focused instead on
getting the king involved i think that's certainly
would have been a sensible alternative but rook g6
i think magnus has immediately spotted the reason
why the computer didn't like the move rook c7 and
what a tricky move mr carlson has just made on the
board i actually completely missed this he's just
attacking g4 and guess what thread is renewing the
threat of f1 not f6 g5 but the threat of f5 is now
once again very very strong that would win a pawn
and the problem is that if we play f3 f5 and we
try and defend with knight f2 there's still bishop
of bishop c5 indeed and um this might actually
be the lesser evil for white because what you can
try to do here is use the net as a bargaining tip
right all right you can take my knight and get the
extra pawn but end games like these uh you know as
the old adage goes all rocket games are drawn but
this one is definitely drawn because the king is
too passive it's cut off and the extra pawn is
just not going to make enough of a difference
but i have a feeling that jordan might have missed
this move so he still needs to demonstrate quite a
bit of precision yeah and uh magnus unsurprisingly
finding every single you know every single trick
there is in the position he will find it and some
more work to do here today for jordan i guess
we both agreed that that the position is still
in drawish waters but gonna have to be precise
yeah and that is just an incredible talent game
in and game out it's never easy against magnus
uh and it really just never is and so far it's
not that he's been unlucky i mean his opponents
uh particularly david anton ariantari they
deserve full credit they defended like lions
they were just unwilling to yield a a single inch
and um magnus i think has has really done his best
he hasn't played badly uh but some of these
lines just haven't gone his way he just
hasn't manufactured quite enough chances fiona
to really uh get under his opponent's skin but
maybe this game will signify a change we'll see
we will keep a close eye on it let's go back to
harry krishna and fabiano carrana absolutely
so we um join here with fabi taking on
e4 going 97 and really trying to get to that pawn
on e4 with his being keto bishop and his knight
hari krishna going knight b to d2 once again the
pawn is indirectly defended so if you take on e4
then i believe that after takes takes bishop
g5 you can notice that the bishop pins the
knight the rook attacks the bishop and if black
cements the bishop of d5 then among other things
um i think that bishop takes e7 queen takes e7 and
probably not the best but at least something like
this would win the pawn back with some interest
there is however probably a more accurate move
maybe knight to d2 uh but yeah knight to d2
and once this bishop collapses that pressure
down the e file will be way way too strong so fabi
refraining from taking the pawn going knight g6 uh
and hari krishna going d5 they trade bishops that
the idea of d5 clearly too shut this bishop on b7
down and fight b says no that bishop is not going
to be shut down it's reopened uh but it it reopens
at the cost of this d6 pawn now becoming a little
bit weak hari krishna dropping his bishop to c2
and um okay before grabbing space on the queen
side and now fabi going knight h5 so how should we
understand this position i think there's a couple
of things to pay attention to this movement at h5
i think fabio actually wants to attack on the
king's side i think he wants to go queen f6
and then he wants to transfer that knight over to
f4 that's a pretty pretty significant square and
he's going to have incredibly active pieces look
at the pressure that he's exerting also on the
e4 pawn and that caught on d6 while it it is weak
i think it's very hard to actually attack it for
white if white can move his knight let's say v3
but i don't really see how you pile up on this one
and i don't see any good prospects for this knight
i think black is slightly better fiona i mean at
first sight of course you you would tend to if
you just look at the pawn structures you see well
white only has two pawn islands black has three
so you tend to just uh think okay i take the two
but the more i look at the position yeah the the
white pieces are just struggling for four good
squares and all the the black pieces are swarming
in absolutely they really are and um this i mean
another problem is that it's it's it's easy to
play this position for black blacks get all of
these very natural improving moves and that's
a very underestimated factor in my opinion
uh in certain positions is it's not only about
who's better it's also how easy is it to play if
you look at hari krishna's position uh you can
totally imagine white collapsing really really
fast but black is all these between f6 rook c8 you
know you can play rook d8 g5 should be considered
so fabi's position is not only slightly
better but i think easier to play
the one positive for pensawa is that he's got
an hour on his block that is a lot of time
so he really can invest quite a bit of time to
finding i think the most accurate defensive moves
one thing that comes to mind is beefing up the
security on the queen on the king side with this
typical maneuver 2g3 that might be one way to
throw some water onto the fire but we will see
i have one question the bishop on b7 for now okay
it's doing a good job looking down at the pawn on
e4 is there any ever uh is there ever any way
we could bring it back to c8 and i opted upon
maybe on h3 in some in some lines i really
like that idea i mean i think particularly
in the event of the queen being on f6 even in this
position bishop ch should definitely be considered
and um i think that's part of the reason pensa
played rook a3 it's to indirectly defend that
night so that after knight takes h3 check like
let's say the queen moves away if the rook was
not on a3 then this move would be absolutely
devastating because the knight would be hanging
nonetheless an idea like this always should be
considered i mean sacrifices along these lines
should never be ruled out so absolutely i think
that's possible i like fabiano's position um i
like i mean what was it it was kasparov who said
something about the knight on on f4 or f5 right
well there's the knife knife f4 concept uh but
yeah i think a lot of things have been said about
those knights they've been you know romanticized
and they're the stuff of legend but for very
good reason the knights on f4 and five
are almost always incredibly dangerous
for sure and there we see our
ten players in the tournament
don't worry that was quite the plan but we
love these shots so so yeah we do why not
yeah absolutely why not no they're great
they're great we need to display them
we warned you yesterday yesterday we weren't the
headphone users should have taken our mornings
that is a great graphic though it's very
professional and um i know that there have
been a glitch here in there but i can attest to
the fact that the production has been absolutely
top-notch our team working very very hard
behind the scenes problems do arise as they do
with any complex production but uh i have to
tip my hat and i would encourage everybody to
do the same this has really been awesome
absolutely i mean they've been so hard
so hard at work i can testify here on site they're
working from morning to evening to bring you this
show uh so a big shout out to our producers
working tirelessly behind the scenes um shall we
move on to the from this one and go
absolutely yeah can we please go to donchenko
okay sure let's go to and queens have
been traded okay so what happened here
now we looked at the snap 497 and actually the
funny thing is alexander continuing not to castle
i was really expecting him to castle
but instead he drove that pawn into f5
you can see that that limits the bishop on c8
now it really can't ever develop to to e6 but
it is a committal move right now he can't really
open up the file anymore and so now it doesn't
make as much sense to castle short one of the uh
ideas of castling short was to put a rook on f1
so the way that the queens are traded knight
d6 queen c6 check right in the into the teep in
amongst the trees in queen d7 queens are swapped
that doesn't really diminish the sharpness of
the position it doesn't mean that the kings are
saved and drinking when b3 will limit that knight
not allow it to go to c4 g5 by ruddick trying to
close down the position i think he is preventing
white from playing the move g5 himself kind of
interesting and here finally alex hunter castles
long it's kind of ironic that he waits until
the end game to do it but i think it does make
perfect sense uh ronislav continuing to shut
down the position and look at that exquisite
positional maneuver by alexander uh basically
just uh he has that pawn in his crosshairs
and one very sensible idea here i think is
to double rooks and continue to attack that
pawn and that might be a mistake because of d5 so
perhaps you should start here with the move knight
c3 limiting the progress of the pawn and then fred
double rooks white is definitely in the driver's
seat here no doubt about it yeah it very much
feels like like a position where white is playing
4-2 results unless he does anything too crazy the
king side is completely close and he is the one
with the control in the center and on the queen
side so i'm sure alexander donchenko will be
happy with how to uh with how the opening uh stage
played out here yeah he is and by the way another
idea in terms of preventing d5 because allowing d5
would just enable all of black's pieces to come up
that is out of the question uh the move bishop
a5 is is also possible attacking the knight and
trying to get that knight out of b6
because that knight is one of the key
uh pieces that is preparing the move d5 uh
without it that becomes stronger so several
ideas to consider here knight c3 appears to me to
be the most sensible movie he has just played it
okay yeah c3 uh stopping d5 and then of course uh
he can double books i don't think i think radoslav
will make the draw here i really don't think that
he's significantly worse i think one thing he can
do is just go king f7 and and say all right i'm
going to put my rook on the 8th yes yes this is
passive yes this is nasty but i really don't see
how alexander is going to really make inroads into
black's position i mean he's played a good game
not sure he's going to bring it all the way home
danya i'm seeing in the chat people are
informing us an exchange sacrifice has
occurred in the fuji game so we shall return
there wow okay so things really heating up here
and aryan deciding in this position to go after
that uh light squared bishop with the move g4
and the whole point is that the bishop
actually doesn't have any squares because
in the event of bishop takes b1 uh queen takes
b1 follows and that knight on g6 is simply toast
that knight is lost but alireza had cooked up a
very interesting idea rook takes h5 sacrificing
the exchange as you said for the bishops he
takes h5 and look at white's king white's king
is incredibly exposed and the second thing is
this bishop on f5 finally after a lifetime of
insecurity due to this g4 move is finally safe
it is is retired to a beach in hawaii it is
safe on f5 and that white king it might not seem
like a significant weakness right now because
once again the queen is quite far removed from
the king side but after something like knight
h4 maybe even knight f4 um black is going
to castle and we discussed this this queen
can re-enter the king side very very quickly d8 so
this is anybody's game this is incredibly unclear
i love what ali reza is doing here i really do too
and i think especially over the board when you see
rook h5 appear i think it's like oh no did not
want that no yeah i think aryan saw it but but
i think he might have underestimated some of
black's play here but the time situation after
only 13 moves fiona 40 minutes barley reza this is
going to be another time as we see knight of four
has indeed been played now a decision to make for
aryan does he take on f4 does he play d takes e5
this does not win the knight because ali roza has
among other things he's a move knight h3 and then
he can deploy his queen via d8 a and alerts i mean
after the positional masterpiece we saw yesterday
today he's showing us guys i can still play in
tactical aggressive style too so showing us the
whole spectrum yeah versatility is the name of the
game and uh at such a young age alireza already
capable of playing such a wide range of positions
and such a wide range of openings that is just an
unprecedented versatility the unprecedented skill
he is just so promising and so fun to watch yeah
and while we see the the bar actually here says a
very calm and collected zero zero zero of course
i very much uh like ali reza's chances i think
from a practical point of view um i think most
of us would prefer playing with the attack but
especially ali raza no for sure and this is in
exchange is not a wrong i mean that's not a huge
amount of material it's very significant but it's
not the sort of thing you do and you know you have
to checkmate your opponent in a couple of moves
so we will monitor how this attack unfolds but
anything else that's catching your eye on anything
else that's been interesting to you maybe we can
go back i feel like we haven't looked at maxim
vashila grav in a long time i agree let's take a
look at the game so we had we remind you a martial
attack as mvl deploying his rook to e4 trying to
smoke that queen out via h4 david until going back
on his own volition i think this is still theory
that basically what david antony is doing is he's
trying to launch a battery by playing bishop
f5 and he just wants to win back the d-pawn
because why not and after knight f3 a slight
change of plans bishop f5 would meet with knight
h4 very nasty little move eliminating the bishop
so now the bishop develops instead to g4 pinning
the queen i think that's a very good move very
good presence of mind for david and flexibility
maxime uh urgently gets the bishop out of g4 he
sacrifices upon to do so and he does play this
move knight h4 getting his queen to a trip trying
to you know rest the initiative from black's hand
strength to get his pieces to the king side things
heat up here david goes g6 and queen e2 queen g7
feather ghettoing his queen leaving open that up
6-4 potentially for the knight and after bishop b3
knight takes e3 queen comes back to f6 and rookie
one leads to the position currently on the board
so david has won the pawn backfield and i i i
like his position i think after something like
bishop p7 and rookie eight or
did i just one or something
i think oh queen d4 here oh that's a cool move
that actually wins the piece oh wow that's such an
easy to miss move yeah it is forcing
the queen train you wouldn't think it so
yeah suppose g4 by the way is not i for
some reason i thought it was a threat for
a second but but it leaves the knight on h4
unprotected so dividend zone has time here to
make an improving move maybe you want to start
with the move rook 80d8s um maybe you want to
move the king somewhere to maybe g7 getting it
out of the pin i kind of like that move as well
just so that there are no tactics related to that
f7 pawn being pinned how big of an advantage do
you think the bishop pair is here for black i mean
it's it's quite significant because the position
is relatively open i would argue that you know
this not an h4 isn't as bad as perhaps it may
look it it does uh open up the possibility
for various tactics in the future that's why
king g7 would be one of my candidate moves um and
what i like about maxine's position is that he
has tripled on the e file so that's why
i wanted to play bishop d7 at some point
and david definitely has problems with soccer the
eval bar liking black's position i do as well from
a static point of view but dynamically speaking i
think mbl still has a small initiative that needs
to be dealt with i mean it could just be a case
that both player is not happy with their positions
you know maxime you just mentioned it the word
dynamic i mean maxime is one of the most dynamic
players at the top while david may be a bit more
slightly more classical style so yeah i think
both might just be might just be happy with their
respective positions certainly yeah i i would say
that the truth is somewhere in the middle i think
uh equality is is probably the most sensible
assessment here dynamic equality as the bead with
an hour on his clock plenty of time and that's the
perk of playing a flank such a theoretical opening
you get to make a lot of moves fast and really
accumulate a lot of time on your clock and that
goes for both players but to beat with an hour on
his clock to ponder this critical position shall
we go back there's two games i feel we haven't
seen in a while i'll let you choose where to
start the asi panko grandelias as well as do the
game first we had this very theoretical grunfeld
where uh we remind you and he's sacrificing upon
to get this active play for his pieces and queen
c7 has indeed been played bishop d4 rook to e8 you
can see that black is deploying all of his pieces
to active squares now of knight to g4 of course
threatening checkmate and basically forcing uh the
trade of bishops leaving white with this slightly
awkward knight on a3 we had mentioned before
that the knight often wants to come into the
game via c4 but currently that square is covered
by black between here bishop b6 is a potential
threat you're going rook ac-8 he doesn't care if
bishop b6 i think queen takes c3 creates a lot
of counter threats in particular against whites
go down this line actually after bishop b6 sure
so if you take the rook right it makes ah white's
one in exchange but black takes the queen and then
it's very important to take that rook on a1 and
after rook takes a one row takes it technically
material is equal but you can see how bad white
spawn structure is and that knight on a3 is just
horrible this is just not a good position and
if white tries to capture on e3 first which is
perhaps a little bit more sensible and at the
very least black and recapture with the bishop
and once again we get a similar type of position
white's pawn structure at the end of this line
is not ruined but uh the knight is still very
bad and black controls the defile so black is
definitely calling the shots here by the way
just to address a very quick question in the
chat by hoba jones how does the tournament format
work just round robin and whoever has the highest
score at the end wins yeah it's as simple as
simple as that everyone plays 13 rounds there
we have it so 14 players here single round robin
everyone is going to play 13 rounds nobody's gonna
to get eliminated and whoever has the the most
points in the end wins indeed actually i'm not
i've been put on the spot by myself i think in
case of a tie we'll have a play-off but maybe
our producers and confirmed that yeah so that is
confirmed i would love to i would love to see a
play-off always so exciting i love playoffs i just
love playoffs and um i've been present for several
of them in us championships uh live tension in
the room as we talked about you get nervous on
behalf of the players but that's far in the future
we have so many rounds to look forward to and
that's what i love about chester simple format you
don't have to read a pamphlet of rules you just
it's just so intuitive player of the
most point wins one point for win
zero points for a loss uh now we can get on with
the game so dude i went e5 here to shut down
geary's bishop look at this bishop on decor that's
like atlas holding the world on its shoulders i
mean it really has to keep everything protected
here queen c6 finally duda gets to his knight
deploys it to c2 and now to b4 so he activates
it and gary goes queen e4 this is the position
on the board i feel like this is going to fizzle
out into a dry i still feel like black's got
super active pieces white does have an extra pawn
white can snag another one with knight takes a6
but this would be an advisable we notice
rook and the knight on the same diagonal
and does black have a light squared bishop he
certainly does if your queen takes c3 and bishop
d3 that forks uh the rook and and the knight so
this would be an advisable judah has taken the
queen and instead gone rook f to e1 i would say
that maybe he's got a slight edge i'm not sure
black has white enough for the pun but i do think
that gary will hold his own here and mega draw
after rookie one and rook has now left that
dangerous light square on efron which means
uh well i'm gonna ask you does it mean you
have to go back to b7 and defend upon an a6
i believe so yeah i mean i i just
don't see like if you go bishop f5
it's not that this would be the end of the
world for black i just don't see a reason to
to allow this uh particularly because the bishop
on b7 is perfectly well placed i mean it's it's
on the long diagonal it's it's well defended and
a move has been played and it is indeed bishop
the one thing i would point out is that judah can
go perhaps rook a to b1 and try to bother that
bishop when he moves the knight away to b3 but uh
you know we could play a5 here and we might see
something like this knight to e3 bishop d5 the
bishop once again re-centralizes itself i think
that's a likely course of events here you still
stick with your your previous uh evaluation that
black is fine but still has to you know find some
very precise uh very precise moves yeah i mean i
think that's that's that's accurate i think black
has it's not the sort of a position where you need
to find only moves but i think geary does first
of all need to be careful not to lose this fund
and he also needs to be careful to keep his
pieces active i think his compensation hinges on
his rooks remaining active and the pressure
must be kept on the c3 fund you can't let white
you know reorganize his pieces and and consolidate
the advantage it's always dangerous to be down
upon an end game let's make no mistake i have
another question could it be an idea for white
to play maybe rook a to d1 and try and push e6
at some point that's a really clever idea i like
that a lot rook 881 and uh that may force black to
play e6 himself but that does create a weakness on
f6 i know that may not seem significant but one
could imagine a future where like the knight can
reshuffle its wing to f6 so i i think that's
a very sensible idea which could uh at least
face geary with with an annoying decision
whether to allow e6 or play six himself
uh well we're gonna let jan krishna christoph
duda think about his option and while we do that
we're going to take a quick look at his portrait
which was spin just before the start of this event
yeah i'm very happy to play here in bay games
again it's a very strong tournament i mean it
has always been and yeah happy to be back yeah my
preparation is a bit you know like not full but
yeah i have prepared some new openings and
stuff yeah but the most difficult is actually to
you know to get adjusted again to playing
chess over the board i think i've played
twice in the a-group in the master's group and
once in the big group it was in back in 2014.
yeah nothing has changed and
it's very you know very nice that
you know despite the pandemia time it's like
almost the same yeah one needs to be you know fit
because yeah tournaments last so long especially
this one by ganzi it's 13 rounds a lot of time
yeah and the games are very demanding so
yeah that would be you know in the top
of such tournament one needs to be mentally
strong because you know it's not for everyone
it's an advantage to be to be fit in serious
stress so i think everyone does it and maybe
not not so much not so many people talk about this
but they do for sure yeah actually the cri you
know don't expect anything i don't i mean set any
goals for myself and just we enjoy playing here
and krishna who is very happy to be back here in
vikanze i mean i think for every grandmaster you
are always so happy to get an invite to play here
but that's especially true this year with so few
tournaments are being played over the board
right now absolutely this is just such a
coveted tournament i think you hit the nail on
the head you know it's rare to play any over
the world tournament and you know tata steel has
that incredibly prestigious ring to it and for
very very good reason this is an unparalleled
tournament and it's it's kind of thing that
everybody looks forward to every single year
indeed and how lucky we are here to be calling the
shots and taking you through the action shall we
uh go to the well i see you've opened essie panker
against gwandelius which is perfect and a lot of
nils grandillo's fans in the chat actually asking
getting on let's just get the portrait
away and let's see how nils is getting on
sure i mean he's he's getting on well i think he's
solved some of his key opening opening problems
and um essentially let's just see where we left
off so before so queen d3 was this was this
interesting move and zepenko potentially uh trying
to get his queen to g3 nils played b5 which is
kind of a very classic night or move also
establishing the stronghold for his bishop if
estepanco had decided to play f5 now then bishop
c4 would almost certainly have followed and then
d5 can come with great effect and sepango decided
to centralize his knight neil's kind of ignored
it for a time and then he plays he takes that f4
knight at five i mentioned this idea this is uh
one of the most i would say fundamental
night or ideas getting that knight to a
very very strong square and uh the point is
that this queen maybe assabenco here started
to regret putting the queen on t3 because if he
now shifted to g3 well that's out of the question
because knight takes c4 would just win at the very
least upon asepenko had to offload you know dump
some fuel so to speak knight takes c7 and that's
a win for nils that knight on d5 was very strong
as if ben got to give it away give push the
queen back and now neil's a very nice move
queen b7 activating the queen attacking the
pawn and before now forcing the knight back
and now he just goes ruxian and puts even more
pressure on white's queen so you can see that
black is definitely calling the shots he's got
excellently placed pieces andre's really only
advantage is that he's got the two bishops
but i'm not quite sure fiona that that is a
particularly significant thing here i definitely
prefer nils's position yeah i agree with you um
rook c8 while the rook is also being placed on the
same file as the queen looking down at the queen
on c2 is black's next idea to to play
b4 and try and chip away at the ponz
absolutely b4 is among the ideas that black has
this all really depends on how andre chooses to
play the position you know andre could also punt
and play h3 and kind of see what niels wants to
do and maybe try to meet b4 with c4 although i
i mean this doesn't look safe at all that this
pawn is weak and one just gets the sense if that
makes sense that something about white's position
that's very flimsy even like knight takes c4
has to be considered in these kinds of positions
uh there's tactical ideas there's positional
ideas niels is doing a fantastic job so far
bouncing back after a definitely a painful
defeat yesterday yeah and i always think it's so
important before the before the rest day and maybe
you can tell us a bit about your experience is
so important before the rest that you don't
want to go into the rest day with a loss oh
your results on the day before the rest day
completely defines your rest day experience
and when i played in the netherlands whether or
not i was going to make a day trip to amsterdam
uh during the rest day depended entirely
upon one thing and that was whether i would
at least draw the game before the rest day
amsterdam is such a beautiful city after a win and
really your your tournament experience and how
and i in my experience the way that you perceive
the location that the tournament is in whether you
think a city is beautiful depends in large part
not entirely but in large part on your results
in the tournament and the most beautiful cities
i've ever visited were those that were associated
with a good tournament well thankfully we have uh
three rest days here so if they were to lose today
and ruin their first rest day they still have two
more shots after that yeah and i mean the bliss
of winning a game and then having a rest dates ah
you win a game and i don't i don't have
to wake up early tomorrow you just sleep
and you wake up oh i won the game before
that's such a good feeling us andre
fenko trying to prevent niels from continuing the
initiative going bishop g5 threatening to take on
f6 of course um niels can go knight fd7 and then
sort of perhaps regroup re redeploy that knight to
b6 or even to c5 that's really not a problem and
black's position is so soft look at how every
piece is defended by at least one other piece
that's kind of a big deal because it really
makes it hard for andre to make any sorts of
inroads here fiona in into black's position yeah
and i think niels is going to be very very happy
here with what he's got you know all his pieces
as you mentioned are on active squares and we'll
come back we'll come back to this one but so far
uh looking good for nils wandelius indeed it is
and uh where when shall we go next either has been
let me just check there have been a few
developments in a couple of the games now
first of all if we can quickly update on van
forest against magnus and magnus has succeeded
in getting a position where he can
torture and forest for about 50 more years
now what's happened here we joined fiona after
this very devilishly tricky move rook to g6
and jordan kind of yielded i mean he gave up the
pawn and what he managed to do here he did win the
a6 but magnus using this over extension technique
look at this maneuver rook h4 i get over here all
right get back here rook d4 now it wins the pawn
if you go rook d4 immediately then king e2 would
defend the pawn but look at how he he overextends
the king now this pawn cannot be defended because
a3 is protected by the bishop jordan has to part
ways with the pawn and you get this three on two
knight against bishop position now and magnus the
torture has begun this is a draw i mean 100 of
draw butt part if it were a pure rook ending so if
uh if the bishop and the knight came off the board
i think it would be fairly straightforward
is that fair to say absolutely yeah
if if you swapped these two pieces maybe jordan
should just reach and take them off the board
all right i'm announcing a trade uh it's like
you know that would be kind of funny if like uh
i don't know if you know the game monopoly yeah
uh but uh you know i don't know how popular it
is in europe but it's like offering a trade
i'll give you you know give me boardwalk and
park please i'll give you and my brother used
to do though all the time when i was young
and i would always take the money over
the properties be like i'll give you 500
and i'll give you this this monopoly it was
the worst monopoly she just gave me boardwalk
you know the most expensive property in the game
uh but uh in any it would be funny if in chess
you could do that you could just offer a trade
of pieces just to give me you know give me the
bishop and i'll give you my nights i would love to
i would love to see magnus's face if you heard and
took his night and just you know went before the
rook was uh before the rook was on a6 if let's say
the bishop was just dependent just knight f3 takes
bishop on f6 that's amazing yeah it would make for
a good shot for us at least on camera yeah the
knight would would acquire superpowers indeed and
why and it might be worthwhile some people might
be wondering why is it that this benefits black
well first let's just another piece on the
board so just by definition it makes the
position a little bit more complicated but in
addition black does have this ultimate plan of
basically pushing his his pawns and uh you might
experience a situation let me just make a couple
of random samples let's say white does nothing and
just allows black to push the pawns but you will
see eventually first of all the knight has to
become passive and after something like rook b2
if there was no bishop then it wouldn't be a
problem i would just shuffle his king around
but now you can see that bishop d4 is a very
serious threat and if white loses a second bond
that's going to be losing so this is definitely
a draw but jordan is going to have to be on his
heels for a long time as time control already
made look a lot of time though to defend here
yeah i think he's still facing down a very
unpleasant a very unpleasant defense here
actually also let's remind everyone uh even if he
holds the unpleasantness isn't over just yet for
the day the players as soon as they finish their
games today i will have to undergo a covet test
there will be one test before every single
rest day so unpleasantness never ends today
it doesn't and uh unfortunate necessity uh
and you know it's it's uh really a treat
uh we we've said many times the fact that
this over the world tournament is going on
is an incredible opportunity for the players and
uh i just wish wish them the absolute best of
health and and hope that this goes goes by without
a hitch indeed i mean i really think we're quite
maybe just a word here on site it feels very safe
we're almost like in a small in a small bubble
there's no no outsiders coming in not only
the players are being tested the whole staff
all of us here in the studio were tested this
morning they all came back negative so so far
so good that's fantastic no great to see you
know like so so much care being taken and uh
i think that speaks to the you know competence
incredible competence of the organizing crew
and uh i know that firsthand knowing some of
these people involved they are excellent and
professional individuals and you can see the
organization of this tournament always on time
uh great shots of the players and uh this makes
my job quite easy yes it is indeed a pleasure to
to be a part of this wonderful tournament
and dania where do you want to go next
well let's take a look so let me see here well
envy okay mbl against anton something very
interesting has happened so first of all david
has indeed played king g7 which we had discussed
getting the king out of the pin but now mvl goes
g4 so i had mentioned this move almost jokingly uh
and and i had tossed it away thinking well this
gives up the night but i think mbl has cooked up
a very interesting idea and this idea might be
is it i think it's to play g5 okay so now this
exposes the attack on the queen once the queen
moves away if the queen moves to h5 i don't think
that's black's fast move but we'll get to that in
a second mbl goes queen d4 check and he picks off
the bishop on d6 he wins back the bishop although
the eval bar actually doesn't like that move i'm
not sure what it is that white can do other than
queen d4 check i mean he is that i might be bishop
d oh that's it it's bishop d1 bishop d1 actually
kind of traps the queen forces black to give
up his bishop in order to secure the h2 square
this leads to some very very complex uh tactical
possibilities fiona so yeah i mean i'm an idiot
i'm actually struggling to this is so complex okay
i think that we have a couple more moves in
the game or no because we're gonna have to
to slow down yeah this has happened okay this
just happened so let's let's take a minute and
uh maybe you can talk us through these lines one
more time because very complicated stuff here yeah
so so how should we break this down well first of
all it's important to go in order of priority here
the queen is saying that is an indisputable
fact and that is what black should start
with uh the queen is hanging that must be remedy
now black has several ways that he can go about
defending the queen and in general uh there's i
think three ways of defending against the check
and three ways of defending against an attack
you can move the piece in question you can
move the queen you can take the piece that is
delivering the attack so in this case you can
take the rook but that doesn't seem like a very
good idea or you can intercept the um the attack
and that is that third option is what players
often miss and in this case the move bishop g4
will have to be considered so queen h5 is the
most straightforward way of defending the queen
and that is the only square to which the
queen can escape if you take a look at
uh the queen it doesn't have any options but now
i believe that bishop d1 will follow this actually
does trap the queen queen is no more squares and
in order to evacuate the queen black's only option
is to play bishop g4 jettisoning the bishop but
the point is that after bishop takes g4 if you
notice this bishop on d6 it is securing the h2
square so black can evacuate the queen to h2
this may seem almost winning for black but if
you take a closer look that queen is essentially
stranded on h2 so yes white's king is very
weak yes it's under attack but at the same
time it's a double-edged sword that queen could
very easily get trapped so that's one option
and if we go back the other option is
to play bishop to g4 in this position
and now mvl himself with several options queen d4
check seems to be the most tempting checking the
king and actually forking both bishops after king
g8 mbl has to decide which bishop he is to take
um i actually i'm not sure straight off the top
of my head but queen takes d6 does look quite good
because this keeps the g4 bishop pinned which
of these two moves will david tone play queen
h5 seems to be the easier one to calculate if you
take on d6 there was the g5 pawn not hanging well
i think the idea is if you take on d6 and i take
on g5 i think i can drop the queen back to g3 and
right and it never ends these complications never
end and now i play f3 and i think the bishop is
actually lost uh you can't move the bishop
because the queen is unprotected and pinned
so very complex lines to calculate ford i mean
that's not even the only possibility for mbl
uh he can also of course take the other bishop
and uh if we go back to the other line queen h5
the other move that must be calculated is queen d4
check and you can certainly take the other bishop
but this i think is easier to deal with uh
because david can just take on g5 and due to
the threat of checkmate he forces an endgame where
uh david will be up upon it is true however that
white does have control of the e-files so some
compensation here for maxine there's a i see a
question in the chat by uh jenstress he's asking
so when the bishop is on d1 if bishop h2 check uh
king h2 and bishop g4 is an option ooh well i
think the really cool thing is white can play
king h1 seeking shelter behind the two bishops
what a cool idea and and once again the queen is
trapped here you don't have a way to move the
bishops around to deliver a discover check uh
black is still not entirely lost you can amazingly
play bishop g4 bishop takes your point you can
finagle your way here into an end game with bishop
f4 chuck now both queens are hanging bishop takes
h5 bishop takes e3 but this is certainly not what
black wants because after rookie three uh g takes
h5 white is most certainly in the driver's seat
but yeah bishop h2 check would would definitely
be possible but i'm not sure it's effective
due to this this nice one is a nice resource
indeed yeah so after king takes h2 just to show
the idea now bishop g4 check loads up the battery
on the bishop oh my god but even here can you
go king g3 bishop takes d1 and rook h4 and once
again the queen is trapped once again black has
no choice but to force an inferior end game with
queen f3 everything is captured and white's rooks
are more active with this pawn clamping down on on
all three of black's king side pawns so not to
shoot this bishop h2 move down i think it's a
very sensible resource but i do think that
white has an abundance of options against it
yeah i mean we see david anton day on camera
deep and fought and a couple of people have
gathered around the board to see
to see what's going on in this
very interesting battle um shall we leave him to
it and come back to this game in a in a little
while absolutely we shall and uh we will keep
an eye on it now let's see where else we can
go maybe the donchinko game because there's
been some updates he has won a pawn actually
uh but at quite a bit of cost so what what radic
did here is we we joined when alexander was trying
to pile up on that d6 pawn and basically what we
predicted king f7 happened rook d2 doubling up the
rook so my apologies and doubling up the rooks but
radislav instead of uh doubling himself and going
for the passive defense we talked about this he
goes rookie eight and he tries to get counter play
on the queen side i really like that idea rook d1
and he just says yeah take my pawn and now what he
does is he advances the spot to p4 he occupies a
lot of space on the queen side and after this mass
trade takes takes take stakes notice that the move
b takes c3 here would meet with rook t6 counter
attacking the bishops that would not be possible
but king e7 and now alexander plays knight d1 so
what is black's compensation well if you notice
these pawns first of all radoslav could go a4 and
essentially just start attacking on the queen
set but he doesn't even really have to fiona
i think that the position is so locked up that
even if rataslav were to play rook d8 and i'm
not saying that's the best move but even if
they were to trade rooks i really don't believe
that white's winning chances are all that
significance uh because of the activity of
black spaces and the weakness of the pawn on
so how would black hole here and let's admit
the works came off the board after rook v8 and
swapping a white would have to at some point
push make a prawn break on the the queen side so
yeah let's say c3 and i guess you would just sit
or yeah that's a good question because well
one idea to me would be to transfer the knight
over to c5 and pile up with everything you've
got on that e4 pawn so something like c b a b
another key question b if you if
you let's say bring your king off to
e3 and a move has been played we will update you
in just one second i don't really see a way to
make inroads for white because that knight on
c5 is fully limiting it's it's vis-a-vis on on
yeah no sorry i let you finish this uh
this variation i was no were you gonna ask
if the knights were to be traded here yeah instead
of bringing my king to d2 i was wondering if i
brought the knight to f2 and then to d3 i would
just go an ic5 that would uh d3 but i agree if
you managed to make it to d3 white can actually
win on the spot because you would win the player
not on time but um knight d1 oh yeah
no radislav hasn't made a move sorry
victor yeah so 91 yeah i for some reason i don't
think we're gonna see book d8 what so what about
the immediate a4 for black yeah so a4 i suppose
is is very sensible here and if if i think knight
f2 is probably alexander's idea i mean he still
does want to get the knight to d3 uh rooks or or
no rooks and if radislav takes then after c takes
b3 notice that the rook on d2 is defending the a2
pawn so the battle will begin to revolve around
whether uh the b4 pawn can be kept protected yeah
but um before we delve further into the analysis
we have a short announcement announcement as we're
going to show a tweet and really the tweets add
so much spice to this tournament fiona don't they
so a tweet from our producer here on site and we
are calling for all of you out there watching us
do get involved in the twittersphere um probably
not with the same content i hope most of you did
not have to go through a negative test today but
congratulations to bigfoot on your negative result
but use hashtag tata steel jazz to to
get in touch with us and you might find
uh your tweet on the big screen as well absolutely
and uh great news our wonderful hard-working
producer bigfoot um water without whom none
of this would be possible he is as you said uh
together with his amazing team working
tirelessly to make sure this production
runs uh as smoothly as it has and uh will black's
defense run smoothly here is the key question for
radislav voyager because he ponders several
defensive options which include a4 or rook d8
vic is being really modest to us
in private correspondence i think
we're working with what we're getting okay shall
we smoothly move on to the next game i seen the
chat people asking for fuji did we have any uh
any moves there are you saying the game wasn't
smooth enough i mean what do you want me to do
he wants me to win a piece out to the opening and
take the game all the way to the end if that's how
you play a smooth game anyways i had to i had to
make that reference given the word smooth it is
one of my favorite videos i mean i love maurice
um oh yeah we all do it's such a funny video no
it's just a it's just sort of a classic and it's a
this is nothing to do with any if it's just
it's just sort of a classic but in any case
um we have a very interesting situation
here in arientari's game we remind you
that verusia sacrificing the exchange with rook
takes h5 deploying the knights f4 and then to h3
so and then playing c5 so very interesting
way of defending defending the queen fiona
i think the idea of this move is to open up the
c6 square for the queen why is this square good
because that from c6 it actually has a direct line
of fire to that king on g2 amazing f4 by atari
queen c6 indeed has been played knight f3 trying
to cover up that diagonal and of course alireza
castling long here he has to tuck his king away
knight bd2 and we have this position on the board
now the computer seems to believe that black's
attack is quite devastating here a big time
advantage for black now there's several ways to go
about this i think the simplest is to go bishop e7
and and then to go rook here but i have a feeling
that there is something better in this position
can i just ask you dania quickly a question from
the chat from roman james can ariane still win
i mean absolutely i think we should not put too
much faith into just the computer's evaluation
here because this is not kind of like an end
game for magnus's game where it's they're playing
for two results they are absolutely playing for
three results here without a doubt this is a very
hard position to navigate accurately although
ali reza is known for his ability to do just
that uh but definitely any results is possible
i think particularly given the time situation
26 minutes for 22 moves anything could happen here
and i say that without any reservations this next
couple of moves they are going to be crucial
as alireza apparently has a very very strong
option here which we are trying to decode yeah
so let's try and see uh why the computer thing
seems to think that minus two i mean minus two
very close to winning advantage what could that
move be um i've been struggling to find i i mean
i've had two main ideas one of them was to play
the move d4 c takes d4 and we've seen magnus do
this against foruso you basically push up a pawn
and then you carve out the square in front of it
so knight b6 knight t5 that's one idea although
the problem with this is that it opens up the c
file and uh that has to be dealt with i mean like
rook c1 for example and that queen then becomes
pinned so i'm not sure that's the best but you
know what is always possible in these situations
is to interchange the move or play knight v6 first
and then prepare the move d4 here this is a little
bit less committal because black doesn't have to
play d4 in the event that white does something
nasty so maybe knight p6 is a little bit more
precise but other than that the only other idea
that i came up with is the move g6 and the idea
of g6 is to get this bishop out to h6 and clearly
this is bad but i thought about attacking the f4
pawn maybe getting the rook to g8 so what about
very just a simple move like bishop e7 trying to
get the bishop out of the way and opening yeah
opening the way for the black work no certainly
that's i mean that i think is is there's nothing
that can this can't be that bad i mean you get the
rook into the game and i think practically
speaking black's got a great position here
um it's it's easy to fall in love with the email
bar and say well this isn't the minus two move
but i think alireza shouldn't get also remember
nobody's tapping alireza on the shoulder and say
hey alyssa i just do you better find the move here
so he might very well play bishop b7 and i don't
think we should judge him too harshly if he does
yeah i mean as you say this game all true is all
still possible and the time situation uh this is
one of the games where we're gonna see some action
coming in thick and fast at some point let's leave
alireza to it for now and let's go back to the
game between jessepanko and niels grandelius well
thanks continuing to look quite grim now for andre
as he loses a pawn and after bishop g5 at fd7 or
no he actually doesn't but rather the position
opens up and d5 it actually almost looks like
he's down material because look at how active
black's pieces are and niels uh just an excellent
decision to put that queen on b7 he couldn't have
known entirely that he would eventually build
up a battery against the g2 pawn but that's
exactly what he's done his pieces well amazingly
placed in the center andre's pieces on the other
hand kind of scattered around the board generally
speaking it's a good idea to have the two bishops
in an open position but there are exceptions to
the rule and i would say that here because the
knights are so nicely centralized niels is
without a doubt he holds a clear advantage
andre has to play this very very carefully fiona
to preserve something like a balance yeah i mean
i like black's position my question to you is the
position looks so nice but how do we go on about
improving it from here well i think like first
of all you know we have to see what white does
and i think something like doubling rooks on
f1 looks relatively sensible when you wanna
employ all the pieces for the defense yeah i mean
it's definitely not easy uh because if only you
had a third light squared bishop to put somewhere
on c6 and it's actually two further um that would
be amazing maybe something like knight c5 and
then knight e4 uh make some sense or at least
just hover on c5 and and eventually go out to d3
if white relinquishes control over that square so
i do like knight c5 as one possible idea you can
also throw in flick and h6 there just to make some
luft for the king and ask the bishop a question uh
so a couple of options here that nils will have to
uh work through but um niels is just he's playing
so well even despite the lost fiona i really like
the way he's playing yeah and let's let's remind
everyone that despite the loss he's still part
of the the leader group big group at the top
five players on two out of three and while uh
well actually let's wait here's a panko is about
to make a move and it is indeed rook rook af1
indeed oh rook or is it rook g1 i think it's your
g one i i watched it on camera and i thought yeah
but no he went one step further
that's not a move you make
if you have a good position rook g1 trying
to get that pawn on g2 under full control
and maybe free up the other rook i still
think knight c5 makes a lot of sense here
um and rook g1 rook f1 are kind of similar
moves i think andre was just worried about
eventually that pawn falling should the rook
on f2 need to move so we will see how niels
goes about playing this position but shall we
have a look at uh niels's portrait he's such an
interesting character yeah absolutely let's see
what niels had to say ahead of the tournament
i did prepare for the tournament but my invitation
got was quite late it was on the 23rd or something
like that of december so last couple of weeks i've
been preparing extensively but before that it was
sort of general chess training so i'm hoping it
will it will help as a kid i played in the c group
in 2010 and then i saw the a group sitting next
to us and so on since then i really wanted to play
in the a-group of course in general i thought it
was not unlikely let's say before the challenger
last year that one day i would play in the
a-group but i did not expect it to be this soon
i think the pieces still move in in the same way
as they did before but no it's it's a matter of
of the very long games and the concentration
required and i mean it's very different from
playing uh you know 40 blitz games online where
you can lose a couple and it doesn't matter like
when you play a classical game for seven hours and
you lose concentration for five seconds it could
mean the loss of the game most days i will try to
run on the beach or do some exercises and so on
hoping that the weather allows it of
course which is always a bit unclear here
i think like when you start to focus
on the next game it's it helps with
dealing with the last year i mean you no longer
think about what happened before when you
have a new game the tough thing is when you don't
have a new game to look forward to then it can
stay with you for quite some time but once
you start preparation it's it's all fine
and despite 2020 having been such a tough year
thankfully the pieces still move in the same
way danya absolutely and um yeah nils is nils
is awesome i'm a big fan i'm just a big fan
i actually remember you know he referenced
that tournament in 2010 when he was playing
uh in what was at the time called the c
group here it doesn't exist any longer
now it's just the masters and the challenges
i was actually uh in university studying in
france at the time and i remember driving up
here to vacancy with a friend for a weekend
just as a chess fan you know to come and
see come and see the action and i remember
neil's very well playing in the sea in the sea
group with his uh with his dreadlocks his um
his infamous infamous dreadlocks wow 2010 that was
so long ago i was like 11 this he's so experienced
too i mean it's it's crazy when you think he's
still very young still has you know the peak
of his chest career in front of him but but so
much experience under his belt playing these
high level tournaments and that really matters i
think that matters more than some people realize
because you just get a handle on on how to do
things how to prepare um how to surmount losses
how to play long tournaments and uh particularly
playing in tara i think really helps subsequent
performances absolutely and let's maybe just
remind people one more time for those who haven't
heard it yet but niels one of the the members of
team magnus for his last two world championship
matches and that experience also i mean it's
not like you join team magnus and that's it like
that will pay off you know for years for
years to come you will be able to use the
the knowledge you gained there absolutely that
must be such an incredible experience to be part
of you know the greatest chess player in history
and in his team which of course is very extensive
and uh is held to the highest of standards and
you know nils holds himself to the highest of
standards which makes perfect sense and
uh that has reflected in his results
this tournament as he nurtures and tries to expand
a big advantage against andrea cebenko in the
middle game he's gone rookie six lifting the rook
up potentially to g6 or doubling rooks that's also
a very sensible move uh he's pressuring white
on really all sides of the board all three sides
of the board are one can think of in black's
favor andre pretty tight up here but we'll keep
monitoring how he uh defends in this position
absolutely i saw a question and the chat did
magnus lose magnus certainly didn't lose he
is still playing he's playing for two results
let's see if he's making any progress yeah so he's
well lots of shuffling we can just see i'll just
click the arrow button a couple times you know
what this reminds me of is almost those bullet
games where you're basically pre-moving and you're
trying to catch your opponent's rook free move
uh you're hoping you bring me book a5 but
of course that's not what they're doing
um or is it but finally we have king f6 i
think that it's really a question of that the
only possible way that magnus could really
make progress is to play g5 at some point
and then and then to play h5 g4 now whether or
not this leads to a win is a moot point i think
i just don't see any other way that he could trick
jordan in this position but maybe he's trying to
to tire jordan out uh first and then when he's
exacer you know exhausted from making all of
these defensive moves at that very moment he plays
jupiter magnus is of course the ultimate master
of sensing his opponent's weakness actually
let me ask you one more question daniel
so earlier i asked you if we could swap the the
rogue for the bishop well the the not to work
for the bishop sorry the knight for the bishop and
the work ending would be a draw what about if the
if the rooks came off would that make
white's defensive task easier or harder
that's a great question i think it would make
it easier uh and one thing to notice is that in
the middle game you know these pawns on h3 and f2
you would look at them and say well they're weak
these pawns are weak they're isolated in the end
game these pawns are actually one of the greatest
defensive structures that you could have because
they're kind of you know like bumpers they're
stopping this h3 pawn is stopping black from
playing g4 very easily that's like the first
line of defense then this f1 is the second
line of defense once black's pawns infiltrate
uh the the fourth rank and they will suffer some
losses due to the h3 pawn they will suffer even
more losses once they reach the second ring so if
you swap brooks here uh i think that the knight in
the pawn would combine and basically force black
to trade off all three pawns and when black has
only one pawn remaining of course the knight can
give itself up for that pawn so i think i'm not
entirely sure but i think that that's the right
kind of logic to assess the knight versus bishop
end game here also one final word about descending
before we moved on i still have you know memories
from commentating here in vikranzo with your good
friend robert has last year and robert trained me
so well that even here i'm already spotting that
word to come down to it that h-bond nice it's
the wrong color if we notice the bishop in the
pawn that's a great note that's a great point
and this square what kind of color is it it's a
light colored square bishop is dark and so uh that
would be a drug great point shout out to rover
tess okay let's uh let's move on from uh here
so first of all just a quick news flash uh
in a couple of games so alireza did indeed
play uh the move knight to b6 here which we had
discussed kind of eyeing the idea of d4 and knight
t5 targo and queenie one and i think the idea of
this move is to protect the e3 bishop why is that
significant because after d4 cd knight d5 uh aryan
does not know no longer has to worry about his
bishop being hanging he can redirect his efforts
on defending f4 and protecting his king so alireza
decided not to hurry bishop b7 has been played and
rook c1 once again aryan continuing to discourage
ali reza from playing d4 so rookie shade here
seems like a very sensible move uh that that's
one possibility he always could also try to move
his king out of the way i know that seems a little
bit slow but i i certainly think that eliza
should try to make sure that he can set himself
up for playing d4 at the right moment so that's
uh what has happened in in that game it will be
fascinating to to see the next few moves here
this position uh is gonna it's just it's going to
explode you know over the next the next few moves
without a doubt and uh the time situation is going
to serve as the gasoline because 22 minutes to
25 minutes that's nothing absolutely nothing in
a position of this complexity so we'll keep an eye
on this one indeed shall we check in maybe with uh
oh well let's go to donchenko where are
correct and the rooks have come off the board
they have yep rook d8 has been played he's decided
on this move i think radoslav is determined that
this position is is going to be a draw and i
don't really blame him i think he's probably right
and just to recap you know what it is that black
has to be careful about as king e7 is played on
the board white's only way to make progress is
to cut into this this pawn chain and why can do
this in two ways so i can try to go c3 of course
after preparing or white can try to go a3 and
it makes sense at some point either before
or after knight t3 to play king b2 and uh
i think what rondoslav is basically saying here
is that if he puts the bishop on b5 for example
after eight takes before a takes before i think
it's just a fortress i mean knight t3 is actually
a very bad idea black is uh perhaps winning here
uh if he gets the king to d4 so i think radislap
has done the necessary calculations and determined
that alexander will not be able to make progress
here and i think that's a very sensible belief
i agree with you dania before we move on to the
next game maybe we can very quickly bring up the
standings i see a few people in the chat have
requested a look um at the standings here so far
so that's after three rounds we currently have um
five players in the lead danya yeah we have a
major situation going on at the top with two
points out of three and i think after this
round we'll definitely have some decisive
games we'll definitely have some clarity
i think going into the first rest day
and we will indeed um and let's see let's check
in with a couple more games before we go on a
quick break a quick final break before we get
to the nitty-gritty of this first time control
indeed and maybe we can i see some
requests in the chat to check into the duda
geary game uh which reached that end game and it's
funny you know indeed rookie be one played and
actually so both of so ricardo won bishop b7 okay
b1 and now geary did play e6 fiona i think your
idea of white going e6 definitely played a role in
that decision and i think we talked exactly about
the scenarios duda trying to exploit the weakness
of the f6 for i think he is trying to bring his
knight to e4 but um my inclination is that gary
will just take that knight on e4 and then gary
will maybe try to trade off the other pair of
bishops still white is up upon and from a purely
principle perspective black shouldn't trade
pieces when he's down upon but the situation
is different here because black has such peace
activity that maybe trading this fisher will
open up the flood gates uh jan krischev has not
controlled he has just snapped off the pawn on
six i mean why not but giri i think we'll
take on a2 so this isn't technically
a second pawn sacrifice i actually forgot
that pawn was saying to be honest i think
94 in light of that would not have been a great
idea because of bishop takes a2 i think this is
heading toward a draw so this one might
end peacefully but still a little bit uh
a little bit of defensive yeah work ahead for
anish uh furnished geary shall we go maybe to
maxim vashi lagrave and david anton yeah let's
see what decisions were made in that game and
decisions that i think benefits it's not entirely
clear who so we remind you this g4 queen h4
g5 and david has gone bishop f4 so he's
finding her third way of intercepting the
um attack on his queen and again rook f4 would
be senseless because if queen takes g5 maxim
going queen takes f4 and they trade queens the
situation fizzles out the smoke clears david
plants his bishop on this outpost on f5 maxime
activating his rook and david going c5 so from
a i think optically it looks like white's better
because white does have the more active pieces but
i do think that this rook on f4 is very nicely
limited by by the bishop on five it really doesn't
there's no way to dislodge that bishop there's
no pawns with which to attack it uh david i like
this move c5 uh kind of limiting the pawn on t3
and once he brings his rook and rooks into the
game with rookie rook d8 i think the position is
probably equal um and and it seems like to me that
this is going to somehow fizzle out into a a drop
which would be of course a very successful result
for david anton yeah and then we see maximus
yeah like i have the masked masked fighter
yeah he's going to yeah nope you could see
him kind of hesitating making motions but uh
deciding to think for a little bit
longer and he's actually yeah maxine
from what we've seen from the cameras i think the
only player who who often he doesn't wear it at
the board all the time but most of the time let's
remind everyone it's not compulsory so everyone
has to wear masks everywhere uh except for within
that playing uh playing area the players don't
have to don't have to wear the mask yeah that
makes that makes perfect sense and definitely
i'm sure the players are being as conscientious
as they can as maxime deciding to take a little
bit longer to ponder uh his next move there's a
couple of options here he can sneak his bishop
into d5 and he can actually try to orchestrate the
trade of bishops here i think that does make some
sense but it probably uh it probably does lead
also to to a drop so we'll keep an eye on that
one we'll keep an eye on that one dania shall we
take one uh quick break before we get down to that
that's all i think always the most thrilling hour
before five and six p.m here local local time
when we get to that first time concern absolutely
and when we come back uh we will we'll check into
hari krishna karawana we will keep an eye on atari
against perusian all of these scintillating games
that are now as you said fiona reaching their
most interesting stage we will be back in a tizzy
welcome back to round four here at the tata steel
uh jazz tournament and dania let's go straight
back to the games because it looks like magnus
might have missed a little something yeah this
this game is going to end in a drop very shortly
and the reason is that magnus and we talked about
i mean his winning chances here were not extensive
but they certainly were also non-zero but here he
plays the move bishop d8 the intention behind this
move is completely understandable he tries to go
uh bishop b6 and rook t2 targeting that weak
f2 pawn but i think he missed well rook h7 is
is sensible and i think he can still save that
pawn on h6 uh by playing either h5 or maybe even
king g5 and he continues to torture white but
instead a move that i simply cannot fathom rook h2
and he simply allows jordan to take
the pawn i mean that is just crazy
and i think what magnus originally intended maybe
something like king g5 but now the move knight f3
check forces an immediate draw and that's not even
the only move jordan can also move the rook up
uh because of course white is going to take
the rook and the players can agree a draw
what else could magnus be intending here uh maybe
the move king to g7 once again after rook takes g6
king h7 looks like white loses a piece but the
move knight f3 comes to the rescue and forces
the immediate draw magnus missed something but
long story short if jordan takes the spawn on h6
i believe that that will make a quick draw there
might be maybe king f7 maybe what uh magnus can
maintain some chances but i highly doubt that this
game will last for more than a couple more moves
and we saw and we see jordan there uh i think he
is going to take on h6 but of course he's checking
double checking making sure uh that he hasn't
over overlooked the trick but we also saw him
give that quick stare you know that quick look
at magnus like what are you up to like magnus
are you did you miss something yeah and he
definitely did and yeah there must have been some
sort of neural misfire that occurred with the rook
t2 which is understandable i mean magnus is human
he you know he tortures people in these kinds of
end games so well but but occasionally he will
take his foot off the gospel and that's that
appears to to have been what happened here so
we will keep an eye on whether he takes well he
has just taken we had the close-up camera there on
uh magnus and magnus immediately goes king g7 yeah
that's a draw rook g6 and knight f3 is going to be
we can just keep and keep on this game because
jordan is about to take on g6 and go knight f3
and he just did and then magnus will
play rook takes f2 and offer a draw
and jordan has got to be happy i mean yes he's
playing with the white pieces but nonetheless
i mean any draw that you can get with magnus
is is just a good result and that really puts
the pressure on magnus he's basically has to
win every game uh and that's not a practical
you know expectation to have but jordan
holding his own early in this tournament
very solid chess magnus not offering a draw though
he just took on g6 um so we're going to wait i
think jordan goes okay king g2 i thought he was
just gonna go and try and oh actually did i find
a losing move dania 94 was losing um 94 bishop
b6 i think it's still a draw after king e3 but
but barely after king d3 this is barely barely
a draw king h4 king e5 this is actually kind
of interesting and king g5 h4 so white does
draw even after king d4 but jordan escaping
the pin f4 knight yeah okay so they are going
to have bear kings on the board any second now
and um yeah i just agree and this will be the
first game to conclude as magnus this move uh rook
rook where was it rook um it was a little bit
earlier okay rook d2 itself yeah that's the
move bishop d8 was fine rook d8 was very odd just
giving up the pawn and jordan counter attacking
the rook and now they will sign the peace accords
any second now with the kings on the board
you could see actually you could see there
the little smile of jordan and as you said
i mean every draw against minus is a good result
regardless of of what color and it's been a very
solid start to the tournament uh for jordan magnus
on the other hand though is not gonna be a happy
camper going into the first rest day no he's not
in uh definitely he is going to be knowing magnus
not that i know him that well but he's
definitely going to be kicking himself
for not at least generating more chances
in this end game we we can go back to that
moment when it appeared that jordan might
have uh made a serious oversight rook t7
allowing rook tree section all of a sudden
magnus targeting this pawn on g4 jordan is
deciding to give it up and in return to win back
the a6 pawn but this three on two is something
that can be tortured for a long time so magnus
will be disappointed in himself but at the same
time only four rounds in magnus with a plus one
score it could be worse and he is at the very
least not going to be far from the lead fiona so
everything is still ahead for the world champion
as well well shall we see uh have a look at the
other four players in the in the current leaders
group and see if someone's going to take advantage
of magnus's draw to pull clear maybe starting with
neil squanders thought was doing so well so the
four players we're keeping an eye on are niels
grandelius anishigiri and then the remaining
two are facing each other fabiano carrana and
hari krishna i think niels is the likeliest
to and okay maybe closely followed by fabi
but i think niels is the likeliest to win his
game because we can see uh the two demons facing
yesterday first of all a very bad position
as niels continues to accumulate the pressure
and knight um knight on e4 is is going to be quite
devastating or knight g for all of this coming in
and uh isabel go on top of that in pretty acute
time pressure so what kind of defensive resources
does he have well i think he can take the knight i
think that that makes some sense and then perhaps
come out to g3 in order to lend some further
support to this bishop on e2 but daniels could
double rooks again niels is very easy play here
he has a lot of healthy moves that he can play to
save some time and we will keep an eye on andre's
defense here but things look rather grim for him i
have to say yeah and i mean his task is not being
made easier by the fact that he only has 17 uh
17 minutes here we're only on move 23 and tania
that's getting to that dangerous territory i was
talking about 17 minutes for 17 moves at least
for me personally whenever i drop on the clock
lower than the remaining number of moves that's
where not quite the panic sets in but i think okay
better better hurry up no definitely you get that
heaviness in your throat and it's like oh god am i
really because the moment you fade your face with
a complicated calculational task and you've got
five minutes for it for seven moves i mean you you
just could be busted i mean there's just no way
that you can solve all of your problems uh playing
only based on intuition it isn't a blitz game and
particularly if your opponent has a lot of time
so neil's not with a lot of time but 21 minutes
here is a lot better than 17 minutes if you're in
andre esopenko shoes we just had to move what did
he play 93 okay that makes sense uh getting
the knight involved now he's not stopping 94.
but i guess 94 well 94 looks very tempting but
i suppose rook f1 is what a sepenko intends and
niels would not want to part ways with his bishop
not not that the two knights would not be able to
carry the carry the burden of the position but
i do think the bishop is kind of the glue piece
that's uh that's keeping a lot of the pressure
going so bishop c6 you're sensitive i know sorry
no i was hallucinating i was so i was so focused
on checkmating on f2 that i thought knight knight
g for but g4 is not just covered once but twice
yeah but i mean you can try to sneak it in there
to get to f2 no i mean maybe you could just move
the knight straight up and bishop before so he uh
observed sorry to interrupt you
but we just see magnus getting
ready for an interview there
i have to say i'm surprised
um that he's even stopped for an interview because
i have seen him rush past me plenty of times
and so i'm very curious to hear what uh what
max is gonna have to say and here he goes
the the annoying thing for me is that i feel
like i made some um crucial little mistakes
in each three games that uh right at the
end like i've um not i've not been able to
put maximum pressure uh right at the end in
any of the games now having said that i don't
think like i had any objective winning chances
in any of these three games so in the sense
uh three draws are an absolutely normal result
um as i said like i feel like if i'd been um
a little bit more precise in in in those
games that i might have broken through in
in one of them but overall it also must be said
that my opponents are are defending well and um
yeah um especially in in those black games like
uh like john played very solidly today like um
he didn't really leave any doubt as to what his
intentions were and fair game that's uh that's
uh that's his um and and is it your opening
preparation that is giving you two little
chances in the middle games i don't know to be
honest like today i try to to play something
unusual but uh i i guess it's in the nature of
of the game that you can still you can still be
be solid solid with white like uh
clearly he uh he only needed to make um
you know common sense moves in order to get
a decent position but nevertheless like at
the end if i if i if i don't blunder then i
probably don't win the game but i at least
get to to torture him for for a long time which
is at least something okay thank you thank you
interesting there dania uh what did you make of it
almost sounded like a little dig at uh at jordan's
yeah playing so solidly with the white pieces no
i mean i think he's right i mean i think it cannot
really be disputed the jordan initiating a lot of
the trades in the middle game kind of didn't mind
a draw but at the end of the day i mean who can
blame him and that's just part and parcel of being
the world champion i mean it's not that anybody
i mean starts from move one and says i just
want to make a draw that's not really how chess
works you can't announce your intention and then
will a draw into existence it takes accurate
play at the same time you can also understand
magnus's frustration because you know he
drops a lot of rating with every draw and uh
it can be tough to try to manufacture winning
chances every single game against players who are
kind of insisting on on trying to dull the game
down with the white pieces so you know it's not
about assigning blame nobody did anything wrong
uh we can understand magnus's frustration as he
mentioned lots of these small inaccuracies that
are a bit uncharacteristic but i also think magnus
he's respectful toward his opponents he doesn't
seem you know very angry nor should he be because
he's got a plus one score he's poised uh probably
will not be tied for the lead since somebody
is likely to win but he will be very very close
behind uh going into the rest day so no reason to
worry for the world champion i think he's played
solid chess maybe a little bit below par but uh we
have every reason to believe that he will improve
his play and be a contender for the lead going
forward speaking about uh someone being likely to
win great segue uh let's go back to to the game
that we were just looking at needles squanders
with the black pieces against jesse panko if
niels can win he will be one of the leaders going
into the first dress day he could potentially be
joined by anish kiwi by harry krishna well
it's a lot of ifs actually i'll stop right
there let's first let the nils see if he can
convert his advantage i mean i think there's
reason to believe that he will uh because
espen go now with nine minutes on the block
if the transmission of the time is accurate now
neil's going knight to g6 you can see the mobility
of his pieces and you can also see how flimsy
andre's minor pieces are if he plays bishop g3
well then the knight on e3 is very undefended it
sits under the x-ray of black stroke niels could
increase the dial even further by doubling
on ea just to show an example of uh one of
the things that could happen you know
if andre moves this rook let's say from
from f2 then bishop takes g2 check would come in
if you take with a rook then the knight is gone
if you take with a knight well then black takes
the bishop and black is an absolutely crushing
position here so i wouldn't say that andre is
losing but it's definitely getting uh hairier
by the move and i mean that that time situation
he's now approaching the the territory where he
only has one minute per move and that's another
territory you want to be in uh especially
when you're you know on the defensive side of
such a difficult position indeed in bishop g3
is his move i'm kind of expecting niels to double
rooks that's a pretty simple move and it can
once again uh put the pressure even further on
andre to figure out a way to stay alive we will
definitely monitor andre's defensive efforts
but shall we have a look at ferrucci's game
i mean i think that there have been
some interesting developments there
okay so oh yeah this does not look good at all for
aryan none of these developments positive so we
remind you that all you guys have played knight b6
here eyeing the idea of d4 knight and now alireza
very patiently developing his bishop and boom
goes the dynamite he decided that this was his
best chance to play d4 one very important thing
to notice you might look at this and say well wait
a second isn't he as i had mentioned aryan was
trying to discourage him by playing rooks you want
to say please don't play before okay but you'll
get pinned i mean you don't want to play before
no no no no that's it i'm not listening to you
because that bishop on e7 is defending the pawn
on c5 which makes it essentially impossible that
white will ever take on c5 with the rook who i
can take on c5 with the pawn but that's absolutely
not a big deal this this ain't about pawns and all
there is very calmly putting his knight on d5 and
taking on f4 crashing through the gates here this
is looking worse and worse aryan trading off a
pair of knights but now this knight from f4 could
go on to d3 and fork uh the queen of the rogue
now it is very important not to fall in love with
material here if you do that and you might end
up relinquishing some of your key attacking ideas
here i think that knight on f4 is worth its weight
in gold so my intuition is telling me not to play
knight c3 but instead to find a different way to
accumulate the pressure what exactly is this way
maybe it's a move like bishop e4 putting pressure
on the knight maybe it's something as calm as rook
h8 bringing in the rook uh neither maybe it's even
rook takes d4 that is another tactical idea here
uh because this is impossible either due to
quiche or even elegance made knight h3 this
will not this will not happen in the game
bishop oh sorry i was thinking of bishop h3
ah definitely possible that that looks uh
quite sensible and a rook f293 could be
an even stronger fork against the queen but i
feel like i mean i feel like an ali reza move
is to take on d4 and what aryan can try here is
this move knight a5 and the way that this should
be thought of is i'm trying to get your queen
off of this diagonal so that i can take the rook
but there is just no way that this is going to
work i mean with such an abundance of pieces there
is just no way even something as simple as queen
d5 preserves the queen on on that long diagonal so
super tempting but ali reza continuing to think
here nine minutes for six yeah i was just gonna
say in the clock situation in this game it's
already looking precarious in the game we just
came from but here i mean 12 minutes to
white against nine for black with still
20 uh 17 moves to make uh we'll come right back
to this game but let's just see a quick tweet
by uh grand master jonathan tissel saying fiorugia
has ability to inject brain bending complications
into positions is amazing very hard to study
and emulate but worth trying or just watch
and enjoy tata steel keep the tweets coming we
love to hear from you dania what do you make
i am just going to watch and enjoy but i jonathan
uh tisdale yeah i've heard a lot about him he's a
great commentator uh himself man of many talents
and uh that's a great that's a great way to phrase
you know what alireza's talent partially
consists of it's just i mean carl khan it
doesn't matter what the opening is he will find
a way as uh grandmaster tisdale is saying to
unbalance the position to create chances and uh
to make the game fun uh for everyone involved
particularly commentators who like unbalanced
games i don't know anything of those though
another idea by the way here is to go not knight
g3 but bishop to d3 and one thing that caught my
eye is if rook f2 first of all you can fork
on h3 immediately you can also go bishop h4
um i just thought i saw a funny checkmate look
at this checkmate knight h3 that's just nasty
little stuff that's just nasty stuff now you
don't want to play in order to deliver such a
checkmate you want to play objectively but that's
just an example of how nasty this position can be
alireza though needs to make a decision fast
he's got seven and a half minutes and counting
he needs to make a decision very fast let's
very quickly go to a game between two of our
co-leaders harry krishna and fabiano carrana a lot
has changed here what is going on well definitely
fabi's still pressing the gas pedal down he's
definitely better now what we need to notice
here and he's been nurturing his initiative for a
while now he did eventually put the knight on f4
i won't uh delve too deeply into some of the
details here long story short they traded knights
fabi got a very strong pass bond he preserved his
monster bishop which of course exerts such strong
pressure on the d4 pawn hare krishna attempting
to halt the progress of the pawn as fabi
given that he has the bishop is opening
up the position which would make sense
hari krishna redeploying his knight and putting
it on e5 trying to make the most out of that
knight so this is the position currently on the
board fabby contemplating his next move now what
should fabby do here well definitely he should
try to harness the strength of this pawn on c4 but
harry krishna has positioned his pieces in such
a way as to make further well that has nothing
to do with anything has to make further progress
of the pawn impossible i wanted to highlight the
c3 square not the d3 square is rookie for me is
rookie for a threat right now oh actually it is uh
rookie four would potentially pick off that pawn
so definitely something fabby has to factor in
i thought of maybe queen d4 keeping the queen
central but i agree i mean rookie four here
uh but here i can give you a check and then i can
notice that the queen and the rook are on the same
diagonal and play bishop f5 but uh even something
like as simple as you know queen c3 could be
quite a robust uh defensive con construction
here so fabio with a pretty big decision on
his hands i think bishop f5 is another move
that came to mind the pawn is untouchable
due to the back rank devastating background
check on d1 forcing white to give up his queen
so lots of candidate moves here even rook d4
fabby i think this decision is uh is quite
important another threat by the way that can
be hidden is actually knight takes g6 if you
look at this bishop i like it that pawn on f7
is overloaded it's defending two things at once
so whatever fab he does he also has to defend
against knight takes g6 and we see fabi taking his
time these guys i know you guys out there can't
see the move numbers they already on move uh 35
so five but still still six moves uh two make um
and i think we should go back stick with the uh
the action let's go back to um to yesipenko maybe
again i think the time is picking down now and um
i think we have a hari krishna portrait uh
before we do pantala hari krishna amazing
chess player let's quickly maybe listen in on
some information about that incredible player
i was pretty busy with various uh various things
but related to chess obviously in january you
just look forward for why kansai it's like uh no
wonder they call wimbledon of chess i prepared
for this event uh not just uh you know last week
or something but from some time ago and of course
since i played couple of events earlier um i could
also you know test test the variations and so on
the first time i played way back in 2001 and i
think some of the participants were not even born
so so many strong players world champions and
not only that the competition gave chances
to many youngsters like for example this one
has many youngsters to prove themselves
and to compete against the best players
well i'm not really aiming for some kind of uh
muscles or like a professional athlete to play
a long event like waikanse or many other
events you need to have your mind fresh
and that can be achieved by staying fit or to
do some exercise so for me it is quite important
always a pleasure having harry krishna here in
vikenzi with us he's such a gentleman and what a
fantastic chess player he really is a consummate
professional that's the word that comes to mind
professional and i mean that in the best possible
way such a hard worker and uh as you said just uh
he's just so nice so humble it's just a pleasure
to have these kinds of people in the chess world
uh speaking of pleasures in the chess world
alireza for russia the young star he is a position
that he has against our atari is exploding shall
we check in on how his attack is going let's go
there um i see the rook sitting on the for dania
you call this well bishop g4 first so first he
decided to tighten up the pressure makes perfect
sense on the knight and once he's done that here
comes rook takes d for this idea that we discussed
once again knight takes d4 knight h3 is no longer
possible because of rook takes h3 but queen g2
certainly still is and uh that is not something
aryan is considering how does aryan defend
here can you imagine fiona having this with
nine minutes and i would still be nervous for
ali reza i mean six this is not easy too man
man man this is hard yeah but harry i feel like
harry uh ali riza you know he's so used like i'm
i'm actually surprised at how relaxed how um i
relax alireza looks we can still see like i think
you can tell that the legs are shaking under the
papers you know yeah yeah constant motion and we
have a move uh by aryan but i mean ali rizza in
general is someone even you know when i interview
him like he's constantly moving i don't think i've
ever seen alireza see him stand still or sit still
for more than a couple of seconds it's he's he's
in motion uh and 96 check by arientari facing
black with a very urgent decision does ali reza
take or does he go king b8 intuitively i feel like
this bishop on e7 could be a valuable attacking
piece it might not seem that way now but one could
imagine a reality where the bishop can potentially
stick itself on h4 and uh maybe introduce further
discombobulation within white's ranks on the other
hand that knight on d6 is sort of a thorn in black
side so a case could definitely also be made
for bishop takes e6 my hunch is that both moves
are probably okay but here's what's great about
aryan's vote it faces black with a decision and
just by definition alireza will have to take off a
chunk of his remaining time to make that decision
but he has made that decision relatively fast he
has indeed gone king to ba trying to preserve the
status quo the ball tossed back into aryan
tari's court he once again has to find a
move now what exactly is the threat here that's
actually not that easy to determine i'm not sure
that black has anything immediate that he's
threatening i think aryan does have one tempo
that he can use to coordinate his defense maybe
queen e3 just bringing another defender in but
then this i mentioned the bishop bishop g5 becomes
very possible that knight once again tied down to
f3 oh yeah i mean i don't really do he probably
has a temper right now but he better use it wisely
i mean yeah i don't know how because everything
is wingy 3 92 check is a fork yeah i mean the
position is so i mean i feel really genuinely
sorry for harry and tommy having to figure this
out with eight minutes on the clock it feels like
i mean as you just showed queen g3 there's a fork
on it too it feels like i almost want to pass
you know like i feel like with every move i might
blunder something blunder for hang a piece
somewhere indeed indeed and queenie has been
played okay i think i have a good i have a good
handle on how these players i think but here's
the thing bishop g5 i well if fischer g5 i thought
queen takes d4 might be a move but actually it's
not you don't want to take the queen but you
do want to go 92 followed by knight takes d4
and you actually win the queen with the knight so
the eval bar doesn't like this move for whatever
reason i'm not exactly sure why i'm trying to
figure that out um this is just so complicated
and and there's so much going on here maybe
it's just a computer you might take your rook
with this and no with the queen ah but but then
but then there's this knight right and then i
take them out no no no i was checking that as well
but there is maybe just king h1 the point of this
move is that you no longer can go to h3 with check
you're just trying to avoid the scariest part of
the discovery um and that might be possible so
bishop g5 is one canada but that's not the only
move white is not actually threatening anything
and that's the important part now black is a tempo
and now black has to figure out what to do with
it what if i okay what if i give you a check on h3
sensible because you drive the king into the pin
but i'm not sure how to exploit that then though
right there okay the computer does
not like here i can take on d4 already
bishop after we rook after we now
it's very important to keep this rook
on c3 so that it pins the queen and this is
continues to be complex but here the attack
kind of fizzles out i'll irisa under five minutes
now if the clock is accurate what is the move
man this is hard hard hard to determine you always
have to consider captures here so maybe it's time
for bishop takes d6 although not just he takes c6
i don't see how that benefits black at all yeah
it makes those commentators looks like look like
fools like there is something you guys have tried
like five moves already you haven't figured it out
yet keep trying no i mean it might be something as
calm as queen to d5 still not the move i mean
but yeah i hope people can understand that
like this kind of position requires tremendous
engagement and and finding the move and then
actually chatting is helping us out bishop takes
h5 just simply taking oh just takes that's like
a classic uh i don't know the evil but maybe the
lr is wrong i mean maybe it just drops and bishop
g5 has been played so you know we're all humans i
know well i've played i played thousands of games
i mean though just kidding ali reza is a million
times more skilled than yours truly in these kinds
of positions and he's uh kicked my butt plenty of
times uh with these kind of scintillating attacks
so once again to recap the bishop is untouchable
what is the idea of bishop g5 the idea is to set
up a discover check sorry to uh sorry i interrupt
you but we've had a result in the game a young
christian of do that against anish giri that ended
peacefully as we see the players get off the board
there and that's kind of what we expected we
have further trades we had a rook end game where
black's activity of his rooks compensated for uh
white's extra pawn there's a full blockade going
in no need to continue this game as we have a
very professional high level draw but let's let's
jump back i think everybody's excited at how this
game is unfolding i know i knew drew unbelievable
unbelievable result here i'm expecting king h1pion
i feel like if i can put myself in aryan's shoes
he is going to see the threat of knight h3
is he going to think well how do i avoid it
i think he might move his king of course i can't
predict the future but that's that's my sense
my feeling here yeah i mean the problem is that
white king is so incredibly weak wherever it is
when you're on h1 you're in the diagonal with my
queen from c6 looking down at the king if i go
to g1 i feel like i'm stepping into all sorts
of night shacks which i also don't want to do
i mean i would love for my king to be you know
on b2 or somewhere far from the danger zone but
that's a rather rather long a long
run and that's not gonna happen
yes it is no wouldn't it wouldn't that be great
it's like oh this is paradise paradise awaits like
18 squares away but what else is there to do
other than queen i mean you could you could go
at it from the other side you could move the queen
back to e1 as well uh but this looks horrible i
mean just if you're moving something it's at least
you might might as well make the king safer uh so
i i thinking h1 is really the only move i'm
just not seeing anything other than that
but uh aryan now with dipping himself to five
minutes this is going to be an amazing time
scramble fiona we are in for a treat 13 moves
to go and they are playing a blitz game and
one of the sharpest positions i've seen in this
tournament and aryan has just made a move rook
five wow okay i was going to point this move out
i was going to point this move out but i didn't
think that it worked but i guess i'm wrong oh oh
my god this is amazing oh this is amazing so queen
takes c5 look at this knight takes d4 i looked at
this wait no no no this does lose so what is his
idea then maybe it's i it's knight takes g5 it's
to take the bishop i actually didn't realize that
it was hanging it's to take the bishop on g5 and
there's no discovery along this diagonal and um
if lyreza makes a preliminary check on h3
then after the king moves away bishop takes e3
rook takes c6 right uh and this is everything's
saying i'm just like taking all the pieces and
at the end of the day it's two pieces for a
rook with a completely messy position it's
really anyone's game here that actually might
happen here let's see what else it does i wish
i had about half an hour on our on my commentary
clock to to understand to understand this position
the players have uh between themselves less than
10 minutes to figure it out and actually alireza
um is starting to look uh like five minutes ago i
was saying oh he's looking calm and collected but
that's not the case any longer well i think he
missed rook 65 that's a brilliant move to find
in time for trenton and not only do you wish that
you had 30 minutes on the commentary clock i think
both tari and especially for rouge are wishing
that they had 30 minutes on the game clock and uh
ali raza is definitely disconcerted i mean i think
i he definitely you know i think was winning at
some point but it's so easy to miss these kinds of
moves when you feel like there's so many threats
like how could this possibly work this is not
fair but when you've got a lot of pieces hanging
really anything can happen there's it's
almost like a quantum position there's
there's a lot of chance uh that that goes
along with these kinds of positions because
you know five pieces are hanging and uh there's
discovered checks all over the place now two
minutes for alireza what is he going to do how
is this position going to fizzle out let's see
yeah so we looked at queen takes uh queen takes c5
of course the most obvious move what other options
could he be considering well i think this is the
other option it's knight h3 check versus queen
takes c5 off the top of my head i'm not seeing
any other moves and after queen c5 knight g5 this
position has to be evaluated by ferusha because i
mean literally it is so wild that i mean you can't
move the rook the one thing that we can notice
here is this pin against black's queen he has just
taken the rook by the way you know maybe we can
take a page out of the suggestion uh previously
just take on h5 here basically punt the ball and
toss it back into white's court so he's taken
and 1965 has happened okay now the evolve bar
is showing eight yeah black is there some sort
of brilliant idea here let's see apparently
bishop e2 is the move bishop e2 what is what
is dania what is going on yeah so rookie one
i'm just trying to figure out what the idea is
but that is the move and i'm i mean maybe
it's like queen b4 no i guess not jeez i i'm
i'm just trying to like orient myself oh rook
d1 oh my god sack the queen we take c5 rookies
three that is insane and then the
knight defends the rook the king
has to move you take the queen your
upper rook that is the winning line
only has one minute 10 on the
clock to find it he has just made
a move 92 check he hasn't found it but oh that's
a big mistake and uh how who can who can not
understand that i mean how do you even find that
but this was apparently winning an amazing idea
just a little too once we make the time control
we'll have to show that again that was just
an incredible line yeah really what baroque won
i mean uh my job was an easy one because i was
basically fed bishop e2 and finding rookie one at
that point it's just a matter of eliminating all
the moves by the way i see a comment in the chat
aloueta tilting bad i think alireza is not tilting
at all by the way ali rizza would be tilting if
as you say someone you know tapped him on the
shoulder and said oh by the way bishop 2 instead
of 92 was winning but the players obviously have
none of that none of that knowledge nor do they
realize okay this is now plus white and four
white and this position is so open with the time
situation i think all the players are think i mean
they're not thinking of the outcome of
the game they're just trying to calculate
as quickly as possible here bishop b2 is i'm just
gonna say it i mean even with 30 minutes i would
say it's almost impossible i mean this move is
so illogical because you basically just put your
bishop on this vulnerable square and if you don't
see rook d1 then you would never make such a move
and seeing rook d1 on demand in time pressure
i i mean i realized that watching from the side
you know one might fail he's tilted or he's i mean
that has nothing to do with it he's that these
players are fully focused they are professionals
and um the fact that alireza misses an impossible
win does not in any way diminish the quality of
that effort that is being put in absolutely and
you cannot tilt if you don't know that you missed
that you missed the winning move and i'm not gonna
find out also i don't think there's any chance
you know sometimes you get to the time control
and you think back and you're like oh dan i missed
i missed something there but i don't think this
is gonna happen today if we even make it to the
time control i don't think he's gonna think back
and think oh i missed bishop e2 there i have a
feeling this game will end before the time control
well here aryan has a big choice even queen
takes e2 was was possible but then i realized
black is rook to d2 check the funny thing is if
bishop takes c2 then white can give this check
and then win back the queen and win the game so
aryan has to calculate that as well but the real
decision is between these two moves does he play
king h1 or does he play king to g2 the the benefit
of king to g2 is that the king is a little bit
more open if you think about that king sitting
on h1 right it it's vulnerable in the future
in way in the future to a checkmate on f3 if
you imagine that this knight disappears if you
have some sort of mass trade um this opens the
king up to more tactics whereas king g2 at least
promises the king an additional escape squad too
from that perspective alone king f2 uh king chu
tu would make more sense but that's of course not
a legitimate reason in such a sharp position on
the other hand if you're staying on the g file
maybe you're worried that you're opening yourself
up to checks along the g file or tonight f4 so
yeah it's not exactly like unfortunately i have
ferrari ontario it's not exactly like he has a
safe haven for his king no it's it's
you're choosing between the frying pan
you know the fire and the hurricane the tornado
and where do you go which evil do you accept
well he chose the g2 fire and there we see a
close of a close-up of aluesa's clock so even
a few less seconds on the clock than we see on
the screen just one minute twenty four eleven
indeed and uh now yeah he's gotta find something
here it things have definitely spiraled out of
control it's anybody's game it's so unclear
a move that comes to mind is a check on d5
you can try to stabilize the situation and in
the event of king f2 that would i think be a very
big blunder due to this check on f4 so in this
position aryan would have to cover with a knight
and probably with this knight in order to
leave the d6 knight which would potentially
set up checkmating ideas along these lines
i was calculating here queen takes c5
probably this loses due to that check on ffa
let's see if we can get the camera back on
alireza's face as the second stick take down
under 40 seconds now for ali reza as he tries
uh tries his best to figure out his way out
of this maze but still 11 moves to make oh
there was a draw for there was a draw for
accompanied king g2 and alireza has accepted okay
and uh that's interesting i mean we can understand
that from tari's perspective who had been
you know crushed or seemed to be crushed at
the start of the attack and uh drawfur is
actually and i i realize that people will be very
surprised but but this is a legitimate technique
that is advanced in in some books where
you basically you offer the draw and
and alireza i think did a very good thing to
accept that drop what aryan was also kind of
trying to do if alireza had declined the draw
and made a further mistake that would have merely
contributed to the regret that he would be feeling
uh at the game because alireza can definitely
sense that he missed something he doesn't know
where it was but he can definitely send it and we
can totally understand aryan's place perspective
here i mean surviving this insane attack by ali
reza and a half a point is definitely something
that he will cherish as a result and a good job
by alirez that's it to seek his comp absolutely
i think for us as commentators and for the
the viewers of course it's an anti-climactic and
to to a spectacular game uh i saw questions why
why would alireza accept well first of all we saw
his clock it's a very well timed uh a very well
timed draw for by ariane towie uh you know when
you have 30 seconds on the clock i don't think
either of the players knew what the evaluation
was of the position simply because it was such
a crazy position where indeed both of them realize
okay neither of us are winning or losing right now
but we will be losing if we make one single
mistake and so i think from that point of view
and none of the players can really be faulted yeah
before we review the the results that are in let's
very quickly run through the winning line again so
in this position right before the end bishop to e2
was the key move now this attacks the rook if the
rook takes the knight then the d uh the d files
this is also a very nice line king f2 now what
you need to do here is dislodge the king from the
queen you give a check on f1 and then you give a
check on e1 the king has to take the rook and then
not only does the queen pick up the queen but it
also picks up the rook so black wins in this line
but that's uh not even the end of it rook to e1
is therefore the only possible retreat square now
rook d1 follows sacrificing the queen white has
to accept it otherwise he just loses the rook
and after rook takes c1 check the king is only one
square and now that is accompanied with knight to
d3 track hitting the king forking the queen and
also defending the rook the king must move away
from the rook white black takes the queen and
black is winning here he is simply up a rook
but who can blame uh farouza for not seeing this
with about a minute on his talk nonetheless an
incredible winning line and uh the game concludes
in a draw so i think if he had found this we could
have given him i don't even know if there is a
brilliant surprise here or not but if there were
i think we could have given it to him right here
and right here and then after just four rounds
and shall we go back to nils grandelias
and andre esepanko which was the other game
which seemed to be headed straight for a big time
scramble absolutely and maybe yeah definitely so
we've had three draws by the way today von forest
carlson duda geary just to recap in tari farushaf
all ended in draws and they've all been very very
combative um but some of the most interesting
results are yet to come so what's going on here
looks like andre is holding things together fiona
yeah so far so good my eyes immediately went to
the clock so both players two minutes uh they'll
move 34 which means seven moves to play still four
nils and six moves to play for yasipanko let's
maybe just click through the the last few moves
that we missed sure and uh basically what happened
was after knight five knight e4 i think we were
seeing this niels uh decides to take that bishop
and ruin white's pawn structure andre deciding
to keep the knight on f5 that's basically his
only active piece but he manages to kind of get
his pieces going again you know get the bishop
active that rook kind of tied down to e5 uh much
like in first atari so neil's saying get out of
there now he goes rook d to d5 he's trying to
put the pressure and put that heat on the knife
you mentioned checkmating ideas fiona if the
knight ever moves away boom rook h5 and this
is a very pretty mate so he's trying to tie
the knight down to f5 uh andre uh offering up a
rook trade and now neil's getting his queen to an
active square this is crazy i mean this is so hard
to defend and the point is if bishop h3 i think
that niels has a very very devilish idea cooked up
he can take on d1 or maybe even queen h5
immediately and the point is that queen takes h3
is going to be uh is going to be a very very
big threat in these positions i i think i'm
not finding the most accurate execution of this
but something to that effect is going to be super
nasty so andre going rook to d4 using his rook to
protect the bishop i think that's a very accurate
accurate move here wow and we we just came from
one messy position no rest for the wicked uh dania
how do you okay how do you even start to
to evaluate uh what's what's going on here
well this is not quite as complicated as uh
atari farouza but it's it's definitely up there
i think the key question is well one of black's
major strengths lies in this x-ray that the
bishop is exerting on white's king uh weiss key
defensive idea is that he's positioned as minor
pieces in such a way as to make progress on the
king side very difficult so the tempting move
is definitely h5 i think it's tempting to chase
the bishop but now it parks itself on h3 and the
bishop is pretty safe here so i'm actually not
sure how niels how exactly niels can increase
the pressure i mean he might at some point want
to take the rook but then the queen replaces the
rook and still the rook on e5 is is pinned so
you know and he's got to make a move as well
i was just saying under
one minute and as i said it
right i didn't know he uh he gains just time
in his life when he asks i just want a minute
here just give me a minute nils just played
f6 by the way if i'm seeing that correctly
okay that's that's interesting so he's trying to
submit okay so what i think he's trying to do is
in the event that a queen appears on d4 it
will not be x-raying that rook it looks like
a weakening move but the reality is it's
actually strengthening the king's defenses
uh because the king can always escape to h7 so
i think he's building up up this little pawn
chain to prevent white from trying to checkmate
him at some point on g7 also this is kind of
like a waiting move as the thinker wants to find
another improving move which in time pressure is
extremely difficult i say panko has just drawn his
bishop back to age three you know i think maybe
just one quick word i think this is a spot where
i think niels experience uh could play a big a big
role niels has been competing at the highest level
you know he talked in the video about like playing
here in vikings 11 years ago i mean 11 years ago
andreas panko was only 7 and uh just making his
first first steps on the chessboard indeed
and uh nils is also a great blitz player and
that should not be underestimated i've you know
i've lost him several times he's he's very fast
you know he's obviously an amazing tactician
and by the way queen h5 here is very tempting
i mentioned this previously uh trying to perhaps
set up some sort of a queen sacrifice uh but i
guess we're about to see his movie goes bishop to
d7 instead he goes after this knight on five again
very sensible i think that's a great move and
he ties down all of white's pieces now they
all have to defend this knight on f5 necedenko
has to find yet another accurate defensive move
neil's doing everything that he can and you can
just see i agree with you fiona his experience
coming to light here as he finds one excellent
move after another maintaining full pressure on
one's position yeah what do you do um what do you
interestingly actually there on the camera do you
see neil's just giving a little shake of the head
then a little stare i i love watching the players
when they're so short so short on time but yeah
i mean it's all the emotions come bubbling up
you just can't hide any of it when you've got
a minute that's not the priority the priority
is to is to refocus and and focus every fiber of
your brain and your being to find the correct move
and the emotions just come pouring out when you've
got a minute and you're either disappointed you're
happy you'll see all sorts of things happen as
i said bank of hesitating and now he's about
to make a move yeah even yes we can't see his
face but we saw the head shake even from the
the behind camera it's tough it's a tough
spot okay how do you deal with with that
um well i think he might end up taking the
rook and slightly which slightly diminishes
the pressure on the knife it doesn't really go
both fully danny i'm sorry to cut you off we have
an interview with uh arianna i was not sure what
was going on i saw the engine now saying zeros but
uh i wasn't sure i thought he will uh zeros but
even then yeah even then i mean when you have
some solo when you're so low on time anything can
happen really so three results were possible but
i thought so there was something like a little
bit of fear involved in the decision and the main
reason was because i i thought i was just lost
like three moves before so i was just so happy to
get a half a point you know i was sure i'm gonna
lose at some point well according to dangers you
probably were losing but you were also winning
at some point yeah this was just an insane game
it was so crazy it was just like mental torture
from the start you have to think about so much and
it's just so much to calculate all the time so
it's definitely my most difficult game here so far
was it your strategy to get like a tactical game
or you just couldn't manage to keep it strategical
the thing is uh it's like it's actually the most
stupid thing you can do against feruja together
like i wouldn't if i wasn't going to say that but
yeah yeah like you get a tactical crazy position
against ferguson that's what he eats for breakfast
you know so just maybe he can maybe he's as good
as magnus in those positions but there was no way
to avoid it for you i could have avoided it it was
very stupid i played g4 i went for a crazy game
i should just uh take on c5 and you have better
there but the problem was i couldn't really just
couldn't find my fight my demons i just played g4
and uh then of course this is position for ferruja
and he played well i thought i was doing well i
mean g4 i thought it should work for me but
i have to check it it was crazy okay but now
after everything is finished it's
a pretty okay feeling i guess
yeah i mean uh before the game drove with whites
it's a result yeah but just like 20 minutes ago i
thought i was i was going to lose so a bit happy
to get a half a point okay good luck thank you
danny i think we can address what uh what
aryan said in the interview but let's
first follow the end of the of this time scramble
between andre yancy panko and niels grandelius
continuing to put the pressure on now he
infiltrates the second rank with his rook
uh the most immediate response here would
be rook f2 but um something tells me that
that probably black has something to the effect
of knight e5 trying to dislodge the queen
or maybe even bishop c6 here uh in response to
rook f2 andre again one minute and he's got to
find something very very difficult here he is
definitely worse and two critical moves to be
made these are the two longest moves perhaps of
his career that he's got to make in one minute
yeah and we see him hovering over the queen queen
a8 is on the board indeed we need a check makes
sense king h7 is going to follow and i wonder
how he will follow that up maybe he wants to
just snap that pawn off on a6 and maybe he just
wants to say all right yolo you know maybe and um
which is no easy task because niels will
have to make his 40th move as well let's take
check out what estepanka will cook up here
so the last move uh the last move now before
they get an additional 50 minutes is it
gonna be the yolo queen a6 or what else
i i mean that looks so dangerous though to abandon
the king like that but on the other hand i mean
it can pose nils with a very difficult challenge
in his 40th move which he will also have only
a minute for so man i okay queen e4 queenie for
getting the queen back to the center now obviously
he is allowing niels to take on on b2 and maybe
his his idea is to go 97 maybe he wants to
create kind of a pin that doesn't look
particularly effective i think niels
can just grab the pawn to be honest i
i'm and call a bluff on andre's move
so i'm just not sure what it what it is exactly
andre is is planning but i guess we're about to
find out 50 moves added that is still of course
a relief and neil's with one move to play until
the time control let's see what it is he was
hovering over the king area so at least at
first sight doesn't look like he's gonna snatch
that pawn and he has just come back king h8
okay i'm not sure exactly what he didn't like
about this i mean i'm really wondering what it is
in rook b2 and i don't see anything right off the
bat but maybe there was something he didn't like
maybe it was knight takes g7 maybe something crazy
but in any case they have made the time control
with niels preserving for sure his advantage
we will monitor how andre defends this and
the other games but first i think we are going to
take a quick break aren't we we'll be right back
and we are back here from vacancy with all the
action promont for what a day it has been so far
dania indeed it's been a day of incredible action
and the results belie the uh nature of that action
as we've had another result uh bansalahari krishna
and uh fabiana caruana drawing their game it
seemed that fabiano and of course that the game of
the day so far has been ferocious game which also
ended in a draw but it seemed that fabi had had
pressure going but he did in fact allow um this
knight takes g6 move and what ended up happening
is that he played quindi when he saw this and he
was able to distract white stroke from its attack
of the bishop however what he may not have taken
into account is that harry krishna gets actually
three pawns for the piece or maybe caruana saw
this and just didn't see anything better and they
repeat moves three pawns for the piece is perfect
compensation so caruana saw no need no reason
to continue and rightly so that game also ending
in a draw and alexander don't join game is also i
think going to finish in a draw very very shortly
so we see a lot of these games ending in draws
but not for lack of trying by any of the players
oh and maybe well maybe let's catch up quickly
on the three games that we still have ongoing
and then we can come back briefly on some of the
things uh arientari mentioned in his interview
and some of the madness that happened in that
game indeed and it's been a while since we've
checked into the end game that mvl has against
antonio uh so let's um take a look at that one
always saw the transition into the end game and uh
they they start taking each other's pawns rook c6
is a very tricky move by the way threatening rook
takes f5 and creating the pin against the g pawn
so anton had to move his king and nbl coming up
with an extra pawn here at the end of the day
but um anton is very active pieces he's got the
act of rook he's got a bishop that can at the
right moment fianchetto on b7 and really started
an attack against the king i think nbl is planning
to meet that move with d5 intercepting the bishop
so anton has to be a little bit careful here
but i don't think that black should be worse
i think if if enzo makes a couple of accurate
moves here he should be able to make the drawing
he's got plenty of time and now that the time
control has been made i might have jinxed it
today you know i came into the day saying it's
the day before the rest day the players are all
gonna be fighting i mean they don't get no don't
get me wrong not fighting they're all going
to be out for blood they can rest tomorrow but
might have jinxed it and it could be our first
uh our first entirely peaceful day here in vik
absolutely and and um you know we we probably
will see this game and in the draw we'll see
don chinko voy tushak almost certainly in a draw
and that basically leaves us at pengo grandelias
and it seems also like assetfenko having made
the time control is making some progress towards
stabilizing that situation so indeed we might
see a day of peace just to address a point
that i think some people are making about
the atari game i would really push back on
on criticizing aryan too much for that
draw for or ali raza for accepting it
uh and one must realize that it is important
to keep the fans interest at heart i you know
we certainly are the first to say that we like
bloodbaths and we like the games to continue
uh but we must also realize that these players
have to put their interests first and if they
you know if aryan feels uncomfortable playing then
and he feels that a half a point is a good result
then that that is a sensible thing to do from his
perspective and that also has to be understood
so i would caution against being too critical of
those sorts of things these players are all here
to fight and there's no question about about it
in my mind i couldn't agree more and i mean even
the word choice by ariane tower in his interview
if i recall correctly literally called it meant
mental torture you know like i think uh we cannot
overstate just how demanding such a game is and
these guys were navigating these complex
positions from such an early point
in the game and yeah i mean i can agree more
with you that absolutely none of the players
can be criticized of course we would all loved
would we would all have loved to see how the
game played out but i think absolutely a fair
result yeah definitely and uh as we see anton
going rook c1 harassing mvl's bishop the question
is where do you put that i mean bishop b3 seems
seems like a pretty sensible move and perhaps
anton wants that rook to have access i don't
know exactly to what i mean c7 doesn't seem like a
particularly juicy square but maybe he wants some
clarity in the position rookie 8 rookie one is
another active idea here it's it's hard to get
a grasp entirely on this position as i said emil
is up a pawn but his pawns are all over the place
and with only three pawns left it just doesn't
seem like that material advantage should be
enough to win him the game really or to generate
significant chances we will keep checking in on
this game yeah shall we quickly see uh alexander
and donchenko and radius lavoiterscheck which um
has once again a lot more pieces have come off
the board since we uh last last left it off
right and uh alexander after a very long thing
in this bishop and game go get ghost c2 and i
think this is a dead draw now um of course despite
white's extra pawn black has very active pieces
and he's got a complete blockade over the sea
pawn that sivan is not going anywhere and um i
think what alexander might have been contemplating
is where to put the king white actually has to be
a little bit careful if he had played king a4
i think that would have been asking for trouble
if black skin can get to c4 uh then black actually
generates very significant winning chances because
all of these pawns are on squares that are
not very desirable for white's bishop and uh
as soon as white's bishop leaves g2 then black's
bishop can infiltrate to f1 so alexander actually
if anybody has to be careful it's probably
alexander and now we might see a repetition
along the lines of bishop b5 king b3 bishop c4
this game will end in a draw really any second
yeah which will leave us with only uh two games
the game we just came from maxine verchilagrav
against uh david anton and let's go back there
andreas panko against niels grandelius who we were
just watching make the the first time control
before our break indeed and knight h4 was andre
essepenko's move executed fairly quickly
yes he tries to yes sorry to interrupt you
we're gonna go to an interview with fabiano uh
karana will come back to this game right after
and you escaped me but that was a game to discuss
i mean who am i but according to me it was one
of the best game i've seen in a long
time what is your opinion on that
yeah i think it was close to being one of my best
games i've ever played um but yeah not quite i
mean you also have to to finish the game off um
but yeah i was actually a bit surprised because
when he played bishop f6 i thought this move
was losing because of what happened in the game
and i was kind of shocked using play
knight takes c3 which looked like
much more messy i mean i and at least there it
gave me like many options while here he was kind
of forcing um so i thought he would play knight c3
he played bishop six which i i thought was kind of
crazy because it goes by force into the position
we had we're after but still you spent like 15 or
20 minutes in that position why was that um well i
still had uh had to make sure um i mean it's still
very complicated and i didn't want to to rush
with my my moves and um and also i was like not
entirely sure to take on h7 or to play rook t5
first it wasn't and completely obvious choice
but i rejected it because if he plays g6 my attack
sort of finishes and when we got to the position
after king h8 i i kind of knew that bishop d4
was an option because i'd spent quite a bit of
time looking at the position before we got there
and um and i was hoping there would be more like
i would i was looking at queen h3 queen h7 it's
the forcing checks where i take on g6 he takes
on b2 and i play king b1 and here he has to make a
quiet defensive move rookie seven because i have a
threat made of queen of seven a thread of queen
of seven mate and um and then i thought there
should be something winning there but i couldn't
see it so i eventually settled on bishop d4 which
was not really what i wanted because the game
kind of continues and continues and continues
and uh maybe i should have just
gone for it but i really wasn't sure
um but i was very happy i with this queen f7
all this stuff it looked winning after queen
a2 i felt like it was winning i had about three
minutes left um my first instinct was rook g3
uh it threatens rook a3 trapping the queen it
also threatens like rook h3 queen g6 if he takes
the pawn it's winning and then i i spend like
more or less two and a half of my three minutes
because after queen a1 king d2 king h7 i couldn't
like finish him off i was very surprised rookie 39
he has like this construction it's probably still
winning but it was like somehow i was um yeah i i
don't like forcing um well it's all very forcing
for him so it feels like um i should be able to
uh to calculate this to a win but maybe
i started in the wrong place with rook g3
uh and i if i had started with like rook takes
g6 and i had that i would have probably just just
played this and gone to a pretty trivial winning
ending where he takes upon b2 i play rook g3 and
he has to trade queens on e4 and it wasn't clear
to me that this was winning uh over the board but
i didn't have enough time to really to verify it
but after rook a3 it's actually very very trivial
uh and in the game i just made a one stupid move
i think the main reason i can blame myself for
not winning this is that i played rookie one if
i had played a4 um which was like basically i
i was going to play a4 and then i thought i'll
play rookie one and paralyze him for a move and
and this was just a terrible blunder after
that it becomes very difficult to win
but a4 i think i would have cleaned up
the game pretty easily if i played that
so yeah it was like just one regret during
that game yeah and the ending is also probably
difficult because you realize you sort of spoiled
it already a little bit yeah of course rookie
one it was a disappointment also in terms of um
still fighting for a win after it becomes quite
difficult i mean i was told that if i had played
like king c3 at kv2 at some point it was winning
but i i don't think i can even think in this
direction to to put my king on b2 and i'm
not even sure if it was 100 winning i mean some
strong engines are are saying why it might win but
but i can't really blame myself for things which
don't even come to my mind so so the main regret
i have is that i didn't play a4 okay thank you
great game not a good result for you thanks okay
so fabi there uh today mostly talking about
the spectacular game he played yesterday
against jan christos duda and well as
he said his main regret is not going for
not having gone for that a4 move in in the ending
indeed and uh you know as he mentioned it's it's
painful because it's really would have been as he
said one of the games that he ever played and it
still is i think that the fact that the game
and the draw doesn't take away entirely from
some of the amazing things that he did in that
game but nonetheless speaking very frankly was
fabi about some of his experiences in that game
and speaking of draws we have another one for you
yeah niels was pressing pressing pressing but in
the end this move knight h4 uh something niels
didn't like about the position maybe he still had
a slight advantage but deciding instead two repeat
moves here the computer does show an advantage
for him i would suppose uh instead of king
uh h8 maybe the move king g8 and king f7 would
extend the game but one can understand that like
this king on f7 does seem quite weak the pawn on
a6 is hanging and i just think the players are
absolutely exhausted and you know we we can just
see it you know they're they're they don't want to
lose as you said fiona before the rest stand yeah
um you know as the games start winding down uh the
players might have an early early end and i don't
think anybody really minds they have a couple more
hours we'll have plenty more rounds still nine
more rounds after after this one that does mean
we only have two games remaining indeed uh both
of them looks like they should be headed towards
draw maybe mvl now with the best chances of still
getting a little something out of today's round
yeah especially because the time situation
not anton's friend is david taking a lot of
time burning through his clock you're
trying to find the most accurate way
to develop the maximum compensation for the pawn
without a doubt the position remains drawn but
there's a lot of possibilities for that he has
to work through i mean rook t8 is one option
uh that seems very sensible he can give a check
on b7 that's another option but this might lead
to a slightly inferior rook end game after
bishop f3 i think that was mbl's idea with
his last-minute bishop p2 i think rook d8 seems
to be more flexible from that point of view
but um yeah i mean black is very compacter
he's got everything protected and white
as i mentioned earlier has pawns
scattered all over the board so
definitely anticipating a draw here but david
will have to be a little bit accurate here without
a doubt we'll come back today well just before we
went to the interview let's go back there you were
explaining the intricacies of that bishop
ending uh in donchenko against reuters
well i think there's there isn't too much to
explain here i think the only thing if anybody has
winning chances here i thought it might actually
be black and black can try to come around with
this king and force zusma and the thing about
zugzwan here is if white has to move his bishop
then uh there is this move bishop to d1 and you
know the bishop comes around and collects that
pawn on h3 now we see from the evil bar that even
this position is is drawn somehow i'm not exactly
sure how and i think maybe it has to do with the
move bishop d1 check i don't know uh but but it
seems to me that uh this is not a very desirable
situation for alexander but i don't see how he
avoids it because white's king he's going to have
to move his bishop eventually because the thing is
white's king is going to get what's called
shouldered right white is in zugzwan and every
time he moves his king black inches closer to the
pawn so i think alexander he's taken a lot of time
here i think he's calculated some sort of a draw
uh after this move bishop f3 so i'm not uh losing
faith in his ability to make the draw here but
this does look kind of scary and i think radoslav
has absolutely nothing to lose he has to try the
move king a4 and he has just played it yeah i mean
it's such an instructive end game this one that
the side with the pawn up is actually uh the one
who's fighting fighting for his life yeah and
this actually might be i'm actually starting
to get quite concerned because i'm not really
seeing exactly what the draw is in this position
uh in addition black doesn't even have to hurry
black can go king b3 first and stick the king on
b2 and you know only when the king is maximally
close to the pawn now you can go bishop f1
and uh let me tell you and okay maybe king e1 and
if you take on h3 this is a funny situation white
wins because the bishop is boxed in but here's
what what can be done here you can try to go
no you can't try to go i don't know what i
was going to say i mean maybe bishop d3 and
like bishop c4 but you see the problem is i just
don't see the zuswan here so maybe this is somehow
winning through some miraculous sequence of bishop
moves but i'm not quite seeing i do think that
this is going to happen as alexander does indeed
play the move bishop f3 incredible fiona effort
by radoslav to really manufacture winning chances
that's kind of unthinkable when you thought about
what position occurred on the board alexander is
definitely kicking himself here yeah he really is
and i was just thinking i for his for his
sake i really hope he can hold on because
we already talked about losing before a
rest day is painful full stop but i mean i
said a few hours ago i remember saying yeah
alexander is playing for two results here
everything is under control and it seemed
like things were under control but somehow um
right at it has a i think it's very
impressive how he's managed to somehow create
chances here yeah it really is it's and and
bishop and games are among the trickiest in chess
because they create always this deceptive
image that that it's a dead draw you know it's
a fortress but zooxbang always plays a role
because you don't have a lot of pieces left
and uh there's a lot of bishop end games that are
kind of exactly like this that one side is of a
pawn or it's equal material and you just assume
that it's a draw and then all of a sudden you
realize that uh one side is in zouksvang and has
to allow the other side to keep making progress so
the other thing that really hurts white
is is pawn end games are unthinkable
uh because the king just collects all of white's
pawns the king activity here is uh is is totally
devastating king e3 king c4 and then king d4 so
this concept of shouldering is very important and
yeah maybe we can announce who our who our second
guest of the day is going to be because it will
be very interesting to hear what he makes
what he makes of this position absolutely and
no better person to have uh in order to assess
the senior than the legend grand master boris
gelfand uh who again really needs no introduction
super grand master a world champion contender
a you know participant in countless super
tournaments throughout the years uh achieved
the high rating of i think 27 80 plus boris is
uh a professional an amazing player and author
and just a legend who is still maintaining his
very very high level right even as he gets older
sorry we have an interview with niels grandelia
so let's let's go there before we get borison
yes do i have to be angry to you today yeah
i guess i guess you have to sort of out of
nothing i checked your position after 20 moves
and the engine said that you were much better
yeah that was my impression as well at some point
i think he should try to just liquidate and trade
as much as possible but he kept the position fluid
for one or two moves too much and suddenly i have
just taken over completely after i get this d5 in
and i'm so active and his king is very vulnerable
but it took me too much time to find this out and
then in the time travel i played very very poorly
and your chances vaporized yeah yeah i mean first
of all it looked very promising with the attack
but even 40 what we got i could probably
just have picked up a pawn or two instead of
what i was was trying to repeat the position once
and then on move 41 consider whether i should
pick up the pawns or make the draw but he didn't
in 41 he played on or he played another
move and secured the draw so that was
very very stupid had i had a couple of more
minutes i would just have picked up some pawns and
don't know if i would win but very good chances
at least and it must have been an intense game
today because you entered the press room
without realizing you're still the leader
yeah yeah i mean after missing so many chances it
feels a bit strange but on the other hand i also
made some good moves again today so i'm overall
not too dissatisfied it's just nice to be playing
some chess okay and two and a half out of four
before the tournament you probably would have
signed immediately for that score apparently but
okay it's still nine games it's basically a full
tournament left so anything can happen of course
okay good luck thank you thank you very much
neil's there kicking himself after the draw
today um dania we're going to take a quick
break and we will bring on the legend
i can't wait boris girlfriend don't go anywhere
guys you're in for a treat with this one
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to todd steele
and as promised we are joined by a legendary guest
it is an honor to have in the studio grand master
super grandmaster boris galfond world champion
contender and uh for many many decades one of the
top players in the world boris uh big honor thank
you so much for joining us thank you for inviting
me it's an honor for me to be a guest on such a
good in a good company and then such a legend
tournament yeah thank you well um speaking of
the legendary tournament i i certainly want to
get your input on the ongoing games but first uh
maybe a couple of questions about your extensive
experience you of course have played in vikanze
many many times any highlights or or stories
or experiences that come to mind in in bike
well it's quite a few unfortunately i
didn't do that well normally in like i won
in my first appearance 92 i typed this
solo with the equal tie break then i won
candidates matching against adams in 94 but
then okay my tournaments were from horrible to
decent my performances but the atmospheres
uh it's always fantastic it's as i understand
unfortunately this year uh it's it's
wonderful the tournament takes place but still
it's a pity this legendary atmosphere with uh
you know hundreds of uh spectators watching and
you know after the round you go to eat some way
and the players who play a other section sit next
to you you discuss games all this great experience
hopefully we will be back next year for everyone
yeah we're all definitely hopeful for that well
speaking of these unusual circumstances have you
been participating in any of the online events
what are your what is your take on how chess has
adapted in the covet age yeah yeah okay chess
it's hard to say but i think uh my feelings are
just adapted the best way possible of course all
this uh offline i went uh are very rare and some
of them where i had to take place where canceled
at the last moment and probably to a good reason
yeah probably it was a wise decision by organizers
but i played few online events unfortunately there
are not that many of high level i played blitz
event i played this great legend event some rapid
bleeds but play some training games with friends
but okay it's very good to see tournaments and
given the posse is a choice i think chess had
adopted pretty decently mm-hmm that's that's an
interesting take and in addition to participating
actively in tournaments uh to this day you've also
written recently a series of very high highly
uh regarded books on decision making in chess
i've ha have been have read two of them and
greatly enjoyed them positional dynamic and
now technical decision making in chess could you
tell us a little bit boris about your experience
uh writing these books what are these what did
you try to largely target in these books and
maybe any other experiences of writing these
these very well received uh recent books thank you
actually the two books you mentioned about
positional decision making and dynamic decision
making were out uh years ago and for all these
years we worked with my co-author jaka bogorton
the next book and we produced so much material
that we had no choice but to split some into
volumes technical decision and the major
peace and the game and they basically be
there are two layers i want to underline this
is books one of them is some really incredible
beauty of chess which underlined by uncovered by
deep analysis but also maybe even more important
the method to think in this kind of
position because what it was my dear
and my co-author shared it i think this means
incentives that nowadays is also engines
uh many chess say francis players got lost
because they say and they say that let's say
chose remove show the same assessment and
it's very difficult to tell between them
and we try to describe it from human point
of view which move is better which move is
less good which move allows you to achieve
better result how to think rather than because
engines they brought a lot to our life but
also they started you know to take a role and
you know mislead many times a people who
want to analyze chess and to run from
that's that's really fascinating so do
you feel that some young players maybe are
misguided in their approach they're over
relying on the engine and and that's
stifling some development of certain players
yeah i do believe so actually during this
lockdown i made quite a few online lectures
uh camps with a a lot of really basically vast
majority of the best talents in the world went
through them and i noticed that and i tried to
share my knowledge and discoveries not only
from material from the books but also from other
experiences and games uh how to use engine to
the best of them and how to try to learn to think
in the most productive way that makes that
makes a lot of parts are learning each day
there is no limit i learned myself each day
you know let's say you analyze some games
and the engine suggests the first layer
but when you dig you realize that sometimes
quite often the first impression maybe
it's not the most practical or the most
decent decision
that's i mean that's really interesting i think
that's a book that many many people should get
across all levels and speaking of well technical
end games and interesting positions maybe we could
get your take on the two remaining end games and
your general impressions of this edition of tata
steel and maybe we could switch to the the donchun
avoid the shotgun game first that seems to be the
most interesting one do you feel that black
has any any chances here let me see let me see
let me see i i opened it on my board
yeah so it looks like bishop c2 probably it's
a calculation of black i don't think there is
there are two ways for black to progress in my
opinion one is uh you know try to zucks one but
maybe it's not realistic another to grab h3o we
have to calculate if you can be in time or c4
would be like bishop f5 if bishop f1 doesn't
win now i don't think any other idea exists
so bishop f1 what we do probably
bishop d3 d3 bishop h3 c4 right yeah
c4 bishop g4 and bishop g2 there are two
moves yeah right so efficient g4 c5 just h3
ah bishop f1 maybe bishop f three books three
they take one h3 yup take one e4 and now
yeah this seems like black
has some chances here can we
maybe we have to go deeper i have a feeling that
it must be some semi force line maybe where we
stopped maybe bishop g4 israeli bishop f3 try to
speculate by transformation opponent game right
you know the margin is very narrow
after bishop takes g4 i mean it seems to force
bishop h3 oh yeah then let's see is then okay
then c5 and bishop gt2 maybe we can go bishop d3
and the both of the sides will clean but no chat
and probably blacker it's rather black or in
trouble because we can meet them you know it's
just mating yeah queen c3 and so many threats wow
that's very cool yeah it's an incredible line we
discovered yeah yeah queen c1 is not possible and
wise king is usually the side of promotes first is
almost always is in is has the initiative but here
it's reversed yeah yeah uh-huh so that doesn't
seem possible and maybe bishop g2 we can check
the electric bishop g2 but probably it's the same
place it's the same story yeah yeah just uh with
the g4 pawn but that doesn't change anything wow
so maybe black loses in this line yeah so probably
black has nothing better to do rather rudder has
nothing better to do than just to repeat and
accept the draw yeah but if if errata goes bishop
let's say bishop b5 yeah white can go bishop d3
the bottom game is is just a draw or actually
right so he has to go back yeah that makes a lot
of sense that was close though i mean it looked
like a dead draw at first but he created some
chances but okay i think also i missed quite a i
i was following the games and i
missed a bit but it seems that
now and now it's no chance yeah yep looks like
reddick is thinking but it appears to be a draw
and maybe we can check out the other game quickly
before i ask for your general impressions and and
let you go so mvl against anton looks like he's
won a second pawn but now he's pinned what are
your thoughts on this position my general feeling
that it shall not be enough for a win for white of
course white has two pawns but some i think that
this is like any harmony i for example how will
they save a bishop okay secondly rookie five give
up one point back but but okay it's not a or maybe
we blunder something engine says us
yeah maybe he takes takes takes for k4
okay maybe bishop d7 or something ah yeah
that forces the rook onto a dark square
our bishop d3 there's ah bishop d3 bishop
b5 bishop takes it was my idea but bishop
oh my god that's crazy it's just e6
wow i mean there's so many crazy resources
in these end games maybe white can try rook
a4 on just on 47 yeah but probably he has
to but let's say king g5 oh yeah also nasty
maybe i have a threat i have an idea if i can
play let's say rook h8 rook h1 after king g5 d5
and try to create threats yeah it's looks very
unpleasant could be made in certain positions but
generally i have a feeling the worst case scenario
black will get a pawn back and probably it will be
enough for for a draw of course white uh problem
gets uh they have to try this two points up here
but uh objectively and they are and he has much
more time yeah maxine yeah 18 minutes for david
yeah for david maybe what move is it 40 so for
13 more moves before before 15 minutes are added
not that simple not that simple for black but i do
believe that it's closer to a draws and joy with
but of course it's not that one-sided yeah
no that that makes a lot of sense well we'll
keep an eye on this game but before uh we
will let you go and enjoy the games maybe
i could have your general impressions on the
tournament do you have a predicted winner and
maybe also your thoughts on uh farouja i know
everybody is always very interested in uh what
you know the legends think of ali reza and his
chances to continue his success no i think it's
hard very hard to predict in one tournament but of
course ali reza has enormous potential he shows it
and he is progressing a only thing which
maybe i'm too you know old and conservative
but i think that he is playing too much bullet
well i'm enabling that sorry i'm enabling that
behavior because a lot of it is against me yes i
know i know i know because it's a lot of fun and
it's a good big temptation but you know to play
classical and they develop different qualities i
will say it's bad but for each time
control different qualities are required
and the trick definitely develops you
know ability to spot things immediately
but probably an ability to go very deep it's kind
of diminishes i really don't know maybe he plays
just with you and uh okay he hopefully works a
lot on chess we can see from his game that he is
progressing constantly progressing
right no definitely but of course he is
but it's not i think makes no point to predict how
he'll do in this tournament the next tournament
right he's really on on the way up and they
generally my feelings that nowadays it's very
hard to judge because okay it's the first day
maybe second tournament after stavanger for a
long period but when hopefully a chess life
will restore to uh maybe not too full but
we'll have more grounds to judge how young players
made the biggest progress in this lockdown time
right it's testing the work effect well
uh and the last thing was uh we just were
informed of the death uh tragically
of grand master lubamir kavalak
who played many times in wacon z i'm sure you've
you've uh crossed paths with lubimir do you have
any experiences with him that you might want
to share upon his steps what happened with him
uh i think that what we got what the information
we got was this uh short but severe illness that's
what's written in the article i see i
say yeah because it's really sad day
i uh less than a year ago we bought my guest of
the praxis festival and we had a chat with him and
very it was always a big pleasure to talk with him
a person with a good sense of humor with a good
knowledge of chairs and the big patient to chest
and i remember that in the during this prague
johanna mafek is a great study composer by showing
us his studies in the lubomir okay was his mind
was very sharp he was spotting and ideas very
quickly so it's really sad news i discussed it
already with some friends today it's really sad
day because uh okay he was a great chess player
his legacy is a big a lot of great games
but also a very charming and friendly person
those are some very touching memories and
definitely thoughts and prayers to lumiere's
family but um grandmaster boris gelfand
absolute legend world champion contender
such an honor to have you in the studio
thank you so much boris for sharing your
thoughts and your insights on on the games thank
you daniel and good luck to you and good luck to
the tournament i hope it will produce
some great games so all chess fans will
enjoy like yesterday games between
karwana and duda was really amazing
i analyzed briefly but i intend to do it in force
coming days in more depths it's really fascinating
indeed well thank you boris and have a great rest
of the day enjoy the games and and thanks again
thank you danielle and bye bye
hello and welcome back to the final stage of this
round four here in vicanzie but what a pleasure it
was to have the legendary boris elephant with us
indeed boris he's one of my favorite personalities
in chess he's so i mean he is legend is the only
word i think even remotely appropriate to describe
someone like that both in terms of his chess
acumen and ability the memories that he has the
stories and of course his humility an incredible
class he is one of the absolute best chess
personalities i think we can all agree on that
that was awesome incredible and so nice of him
to jump on the call dania let's go back to the
games is mvl maybe making a little progress here
yeah i mean mbl found i think this idea with
with d5 and we had consider i think boris
actually proposed this and it certainly is scary
i mean white has to have nerves of steel to go
for something because he's he's lining up all of
his rooks on the eighth all of his rooks and his
bishop all of his pieces on the a file and he's
kind of leaving his king for the time being to
the wolves and davidson trying to exploit that
centralizing his own king but let's not forget
white is up uh two puns and uh speaking of nerves
of steel mbl has them and i think we should
find out a little bit more about the beast from
leon we have his portrait ready for consumption
it's my first time in vacancy i've played in
the b section in 2007 and then in the a section
as a masters in 2011 and 2015. so it's been
quite quite a while since since i've been here
what can be played what should be played i mean
there's a lot of things i can do there's a lot of
openings i've been playing in the past few months
so you will see other tournaments and tournaments
and false which openings i choose to play as
a chess player i started to understand that i
needed to be fitter it has paid off already in
terms of fitness but of course there's still
a lot of work to do i think you know being fit
physically also means you're going to be fit uh
mentally i mean unless some personal
stuff is happening most games i'm not
very competitive if not for chess but i'm only
competitive whenever i have a feeling i can
i can win or i can be on top other than that i
don't really care about the competition as much
and try more to enjoy of course over the world
it's all about winning and you know trying to
achieve my goals many great competitors who won
the event and i would very much like to be one of
them mvl who hadn't been here in vicanza since
2015 but it's certainly great great to have him
back as we see him yawning away there i mean
it's a it's a ruling it's a grueling tournament
and i'm sure everyone is looking forward to
the the first dress day tomorrow indeed indeed
indeed and uh you know exhaustion is hard to hide
and uh you know mvl and together with duda and
others speaking about the importance of fitness
and in light of how grueling these games are
that is absolutely no surprise the kind of mental
fortitude required to main maintain a high level
throughout hours and hours and hours of this uh
is is unthinkable and of course mental fortitude
cannot be achieved without physical fitness
that connection has been well established so
mvl trying to push a small advantage here against
david and uh wow just uh such a grueling game and
uh we'll see if he's able to manufacture any
chances here yeah actually well here interestingly
enough if we look at the clock situations
david anton could find himself in another um
in another time pressure situation because he
only has 11 minutes for the remaining 12 moves
they are currently on move 48 so move 60 is
the final time control where they get an extra
final 15 minutes and it's
actually not so easy here still
a lot of things to be considered oh absolutely and
uh boris uh in the end mentioned that white's king
is is in some danger we talked about this before
we looked at portrait uh you know don't laugh but
he needs to be careful because if you fall in love
with the extra pawns and you maybe go back to c4
you try to protect everything already white can
get mated very easily here bishop before check
it's checkmate f3 rook b2 king g through rook
g1 and you're just gonna get ladder mated so
i'm not saying mbl is going to do that but you
have to be on your heels and he goes d6 i think
that's a great move now he jettisons his pawn and
after king takes d6 the reason he does this is to
provide more mobility to his rooks and also
to expose the king a little bit black's king
was hiding behind that pawn one thing to
consider is the move bishop d3 in this position
uh and that doesn't blunder the bishop of course
white reclaims the bishop with rook d4 and rook
takes d3 i would say in a position like this
with four rooks on the board white actually has
pretty decent winning chances i don't know if he
specifically wants to play bishop d3 i guess we're
about to find out but this does look like a very
sensible mode yeah bishop d3 has just appeared it
has been played yeah yeah that's a great great
idea by mbl uh to minimize the risk now he's of
course in no more danger of getting attracted uh
and david anton it really seems like at some point
he was he was comfortably in in the driver's seat
and uh it's just it would be heartbreaking for
him to lose another one of these very narrow end
games i think his drawing chances still outweigh
mdl's winning chances but this is beginning to
look a little bit grimtiona yeah i mean he did
such a brilliant job against magnus carlsen the
other day but he's gonna have to produce a similar
a similar defensive effort effort here
today to to hold this game in the balance
indeed and just to recap what happens
in the event of this end game well
it's not hard to get a read on the situation white
just has an extra apon and the g pawn is also weak
so why does all of these threats you know rook
g3 rook a6 rook g5 and if fight wins a second
pawn then the situation gets really dark for mbl
the king on c6 is sort of caught in the crossfire
of the rook that doesn't help at all the king on
g2 meanwhile is really safe uh that pawn on f2 is
sheltering the king from any checks along the
second ring which makes black's defensive task
even harder so i don't know this looks very nasty
for black indeed dania i just saw a really nice
comment in the in the twitch uh chat by pittiglife
saying these two hosts make me want to learn and
play chess started yesterday and loving it it's
never too late indeed it's never too late to learn
how to flinch the play charts and enjoy enjoy
the game especially if you're new to it i know
it's quite an advanced level here but it's
so great so great to have you all with us
and indeed never too late indeed thank you for
that comment that's very sweet and as david anton
does capture the bishop on dvd we will see
on the board this end game it might be worth
actually going to e6 it occurred to me in order to
lend uh as much support as you can to that on g6
or by the same token kingdom seven also seems
possible we will see what decision david makes as
he's got yeah he's got ten minutes for about nine
moves this isn't the most complicated position
but he has to find a defensive
construction that's robust and one
uh final thing that i'll propose before
maybe we can switch to the other game
is putting the rook on the sixth rank and giving
the spawn full support of one of the rooks
keeping the other rook active and potentially
putting that other rook behind the pass pawn so
you know apportioning the labor here is very
important between the rooks in order to avoid any
of these um nasty things from coming to fruition
we will see how david defends this he goes thing
he says should we go check in with the bishop
ending alexander donchenko and radic voitersheik
yeah so we're going to see a draw here and
with boris we were calculating the fascinating
ramifications of the move bishop f1 and we
concluded that this only looks for trouble after
bishop takes h3 c4 um white actually wins the game
and there's this amazing line i can repeat this
line after bishop g2 or let's say bishop takes g4
white plays the move bishop e2 now if black takes
then the king is able to stop black spawns but
black is not able to stop white spawns so black
must refrain from the trade and then pave the way
for his pawn so you get upon race actually first
you play bishop d3 that's the key you stop the
bishop from capturing on e4 you get a pawn race
and it seems like black remotes first but no white
remote second doesn't matter black has no checks
and his king is absolute toast white's queen and
bishop is going to eat that black king alive so
roddick very prudently deciding not to go for this
line instead he sort of plays king king a3 and we
are going to see here a repetition of moves i
think we're going to see bishop d3 bishop a2
and uh this game is going to conclude in a draw
any second alexander of course despite having
the extra pawn cannot make any progress due to the
immense activity of black species and he does play
bishop d3 this game will end in repetition very
shortly yeah let's maybe just stick around with
the camera for a second alexander has just played
bishop d3 i think we might just see a draw right
right here bishop a2 and it looks like the players
are repeating they are and there should be five by
alexander we will see a stoppage of the box i'm
not going to say a handshake this time there will
be no handshake but a stoppage of the clocks
and a signing of the peace treaty will occur
in just one moment and here comes a three-time
repetition roddick recording is move and calling
over the arbiter and this one is in the books
as well another draw and this only leaves fiona
mvl against davidsonas maxine trying to be the
only one who can strike with a victory before
the wrestling what do you think what are the
odds that uh maxime is going to win his game
not very high i mean the reality is his
chances are by the way sorry daniel just
can you see the the mouth can we go back to that
camera i love alexander's donchenko's mask it's
not really a face mask it's like a bandana but he
always looks like i don't know is it like a cowboy
i don't know it's it's just i find it so funny
and i love that the players are bringing different
different styles of face masks to the tournament
absolutely and i think before we transition back
to mbl's game do we have another tweet to show
yeah so i saw i saw a tweet during one of our
breaks and thanks for getting in touch a tweet
from jens peterson saying could i explain how
the players handled their food situation this year
uh since the players and staff are in a covet-free
bubble here at tata steel does that mean that we
all eat at the hotel or does the bubble include
our favorite restaurants and for the staff
too so indeed this year is a very special
year in that we're in the middle of a pandemic
and in it does indeed mean that all of us
the staff and the players we all eat at the at
the hotel so the hotel does the kitchen is open
but the restaurants some of our
favorite restaurants here in vaikansei
everyone who has been in vikenzie knows
the famous italian restaurant tarantala
you've if you've been here you will have seen
all the best players in the world at tarantella
from magnus carlson to vishyana everyone has been
there dania i think you have been there as well
uh they are all thankfully open for takeaway so
we can still we can still get our favorite pizza
at klein switzerland for those who have been
here also open for take away as a zona vanc
so they're open for take away but unfortunately
we have to eat the food in the room
yeah and that's the situation very
interesting sona monk has the best
french onion soup for some reason i still
remember it i lost that i miss wake up
yup and pizzeria of course that pizza is absolute
killer man so much soccer pizza i'm going to i'm
going to make a beeline for something hearty right
after the commentary ends i'm starving so all this
soccer food let's hope mbl uh well i was gonna say
hopefully they hurry up but i think the players i
know rosham via if he can get to win he's gonna
sit here for another two hours if he hasn't yeah
let's go back to his game no this this one this
game is gonna is he's going to take up every
second of those 40 minutes trying to uh trying to
win this position now i will say that his chances
are quite slim and and the reason is uh the reason
is that i just don't see how white white's going
to make progress because the moment he starts
pushing his pawn black can get his rook to a1
and this other rook just as we discussed david has
positioned it such that it defends the pawn on g6
i just don't see any targets here there's
attempts he can torture him for forever um
but um i just don't really see it happening
to be honest let's see we have some super
cameras here in the playing hall let's see
if we can get a close-up of the board and
inspect the action okay so we're going in inch
by inch and here we are there we go zooming in
and we're zooming in even more uh-oh
and are we zooming in even more
nice nice nice
those cameras i mean that's impressive i
know look at that that is just you don't
get that every day that's really cool yeah that
is high that's just high-tech stuff right there
i i hope dgt uh paid paid as well for this uh
product placement wow look at like is that it
wow that is working incredible and zooming back
out no i'm laughing but it's actually really cool
yeah you can see the dust particles on the
board that is the kind of definition and the
zoom quality in these cameras it's incredible
technology is uh what can i say technology is
impressive it really is it really is as david
ponders where to put that king of his which is
in check and uh we think that he will put it on g7
riveting end game here between the field and david
okay let's see let's see in the chat what do
people think how is this game going to end let
us know your thoughts i'll ask you as well dania
in terms of percentage what are the chances uh
this is going to end in a draw and what are the
chances amviel is going to squeeze out the win
i'm going to give it like 80 chance of a draw
especially because when move 60 right he's gonna
get 15 more minutes which is not actually that
much time but it the thing is like he doesn't
have to make that many decisions it's not like
one of those positions where nbl has like five
different tries and you know you try this that and
the other thing uh at some point nbl is going to
have to start pushing his pawn david's own as
i explained we'll put his work behind it and uh
you'll get a situation like this and maybe if mbo
can try to push this bomb through to a6 somehow a7
you can try to use checks against black's king
that's where the 20 comes from but david given
his defense against magnus i do have confidence
in his ability to save this position and to make
that drug and looking at the chat i think they
are even giving it more than an eighty percent
i barely saw any mvl win uh votes in there so
looks like we are all all expecting a draw meaning
everyone is gonna go into the restaurant nobody
is going to go into the rest day feeling entirely
miserable indeed and that would be you know all
draws but so many combative games today and we
we've had our fun that's for sure you know so
and that's understandable uh the players will eat
in peace they will not be will not be angry at all
take a deep breath everyone's on the board and um
yeah as we see we need to step away to g7
with this game yeah and mvl okay so let's
see how can we i guess the only winning plan is to
mobilize the the a pawn yeah but there's nothing
there's really nothing zero i mean because after
a4 i wouldn't say he will offer a draw i would do
something like this put the rook on f4 just try
to stop black from winning the pawn with before
but uh david what he can do is he can go rook
a2 he can also tie himself to this pawn and the
biggest issue is you know let's say that white
goes rook a7 and a5 blackjack rook b5 and after
a6 or b6 it's already a drop because the pawn
is lost there's just nothing to be done here at
all and uh it's only a matter of finding the right
placements for um for his rooks and as he ponders
that i believe that we have an interview with the
one and only anish giri correct that is correct
anish without really knowing what was going on
i told some reporter uh that you had sort of to
fight for a dog was that correct yeah maybe i
don't know i um it was a theoretical variation
i think until very far it was all played before
at least that's what i thought at least that's
what i knew and um and then i had a choice to
keep the queens on the board because i have
compensation for the for the pawn and pawn down
but i have two bishops first i was planning to
keep the queens on the board and i was not sure
if my compensation is good enough to play for
more than equality or not and i was choosing
a lot and um yeah double guessing there but
finally i decided to trade the queens and then
i'm playing just just for equality i don't think
i was ever in great danger i think the
safety margin is enormous in such positions
but uh yeah it was an interesting choice
in the before to keep the queens or not
decided to to take the easy route here okay
and now tomorrow is the first rest day are you
satisfied with your plate so far yeah the rest day
is very welcome because my last few tournaments i
usually play around three days long so this is
already today is the fourth day i'm feeling you
know feeling the heat so yeah rest day is great
uh so far the place okay um please okay yeah
i honestly i was hoping to get chances yesterday
um but i really didn't get any i was actually
only you know on the worst side for the most part
of the game so didn't really get chances i must
say that a lot is about getting chances in modern
chess everybody's well prepared it's very hard and
you already got used to the new conditions here i
can say yeah yeah no it was fine i was at first a
little bit concerned that you know this would be
very empty and silent and it would feel lonely
but you know once the game starts actually i'm so
focused and have so many problems to solve that
it doesn't seem to be an issue
at all okay thank you thank you
anishkayi looking forward to the first rest
day as i think we all do i mean it's a good
thing i think without the three rest days
it might might seem like a lot to people
watching the tournament from afar like why do
these guys why can't we watch any chess today
why is there yet another yet another rest day but
when you're here playing uh it's a different story
yeah and hopefully we've transmitted some
of the the reasons behind that i mean
if there are no rest days the players would
literally collapse from exhaustion and so
would we uh because there's just so much going on
every day and the players you might have one game
you know don't they get a chance to have to be
well they do but it's it's just it's not enough
and that extra day of full sleep fully unplugged
that is just absolutely necessary uh to keep their
energy levels at least reasonably high yeah and
i'm curious this year what not much is going to
be done on the on the rest day here in vike well
we're still in a pandemic everything is closed uh
most players are still still in doing their
quarantine actually i think the quarantine for
most players will end on the 23rd so even if we
wanted to go somewhere we wouldn't be allowed um
and yeah mvl mvl he is probably tired but even
more than the tiredness he wants to try and see
if he can squeeze something out there was a poll
in the chat and 68 people still believe that mvl
can win the game yeah i mean that's interesting
because well one thing to notice here king g3
would threaten checkmate just kind of funny
but davina's son that has seen that and um that
represents my mental state at the moment and rook
f6 i think is the saving move here opening up that
f5 square for the king so you can still give a
check that's your king f5 you can even trade rooks
but if you look at how awkward white species
are he's just gonna end up losing that pawn
and uh even if he doesn't this is still a
dead draw so i would be i would put some
faith into david's defensive capabilities here
i probably mexican is going to end up playing a4
but um after rookie two you know he's very
likely to to lose that pawn time control
is almost at hand so that he will get those
additional 15 minutes to make sure that he can
retain his precision as he tries to round this
effort off yeah i think here well he only has
three more moves uh to make i think there
shouldn't be too many problems making this uh
final time control and i also i i agree with
you i think he's already shown you know like
i think the end game against magnus he was
under a lot more pressure uh than he is
here he did great then and i don't think we're
going to see a collapse from david anton here
no unless there's some sort of a crazy blunder
and one idea that occurred to me to go rook to a3
and you're hoping that black goes rook have six
and tries to trade rooks and then swings back to
d3 and the rook is lost king f5 rook f3 but this
is all all pipe dreams david will not plunder such
a thing he can just go i mean maybe rook v5 is
inaccurate there are some um some issues but i'm
sure the david will solve them successfully
and as he does let us remind everybody of
the results today well uh they are not hard to
recap are they here because there's only one
type of results they are not and actually after
that we're probably not gonna stick around until
the end because there's so much more chess action
tonight title tuesday just started 15 minutes ago
we'll send you guys there in a sec but yeah
the results they have all ended peacefully
that does not mean the games were uneventful
far from it especially if you haven't seen
them you're just tuning in now make sure to
check out the game between arie and tawi and
alireza furuja lots and lots and lots of fireworks
and our prediction is that this last game between
mvl and david anton is going to end in a draw
as well then next up we're going to remind you
of the schedule tomorrow if you tune in at two
o'clock you're not going to find us because it is
a west day the first of three rest day dania and
myself we'll be back on the 21st i actually need
to go to my laptop to see what day that is that
is first day so two days from now is first day
we'll be back at 2 p.m central european time
which is the local time here in vikenzi and
we'll be with you two more rounds around five
and round six after that we have a switch up
in commentary teams round seven you will have
texts of it and simon williams the ginger gm and
finally the last six rounds of the event uh you'll
have sopico guramish philly and mr robert has so
lots more to look forward to and dania before we
end the show let's just look at the pairings for
the round uh after the rest day absolutely let's
uh see who plays suez the log jam at the top that
uh that was formed at the end of the last
round it remains at the end of this round
so the pairings are going to define a lot here
we can see carlson playing don't you go that's
a game that magnus is definitely going to try
to win fabi same here with sepenko rendelius
that's hilarious um but yeah uh
american grandmaster niels mendelius and
swedish grandma's pregnant for a while
mouthwatering matcha that we will look forward
to as the youngsters take on each other both in
very good form we will be keeping a close eye on
that game and that will be coming your way once
again not not tomorrow but the day after tomorrow
absolutely and we are going to end this show here
once again a big thank you to all of you guys who
watched us throughout the day tanya thank you and
enjoy enjoy your rest day as well as all
of you guys watching us and i think we're
going to send you over to the coverage
of title tuesday so lots more chess as
i said to look forward to have a good one
thanks for watching everyone yeah thank you
everybody
you